so it's uh we're chilling it's a Friday
night there's a bunch of news but the
big story that just seems to dominate
the news headline is that some blowhard
guy yells at okazuk or tests who we love
by the way that she's a big booty latina
and this dominates the news cycle that's
all anybody's going to talk about and
surprisingly the story actually has
still dominated the news cycle today
because AOC she made a video where I
guess she called her booty juicy or
something it sure did oh man it's just
crazy this is uh yeah because no one
said that and it's like Freudian slip
what are you talking about but um here's
the thing that I didn't realize I didn't
realize that in resp it was in response
to that that she called January 6
essentially an inside job so uh this is
intriguing and we're going to be talking
with uh Alex Stein the man himself who
said that AOC was a big booty latina to
talk about that but also uh you know
I've mentioned that you know Alex you do
a bunch of culture jamming stuff which
is actually particularly effective in
terms of well culture jamming getting
getting a message out making points and
things like that so it's a Friday night
we're gonna be chilling we're going to
talk about all that stuff before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
a member we've got a really awesome
lineup from this week I just gotta
recommend go to go if you click the
members only section at timcast.com the
Dave Landau member podcast was just so
insanely funny I keep shouting out that
man is a genius we had him and Jamie
killstein and we were laughing
relentlessly it was just really really
good you want to support our work sign
up at timcast.com but check out the
members only section we're going to be
reformatting the website we were delayed
on the announcement for like the 80th
week in a row but it's coming don't
worry developments are underway and uh
we are going to be kind of like
shuffling around and renaming things so
it's easier for you to find we're
probably going to call the after hours
show like after hours uncensored or
something like that so you can more
easily find it and uh don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
without further Ado Mr Alex Stein
primetime99 Alex Stein on the ground all
the time the king of culture jamming
it's an honor and a pleasure to be here
Tim I'm a big fan and let's just say
this though I have to you know get a
little manitude because I saw a 22
minute video where you got a little mad
at me which is fair you know I kind of
that's kind of part of it I do want to
evoke some sort of emotional response
and I did have Tim you know a little
emotionally triggered which I like but
now you're realizing it's what I did by
calling AOC a big booty latina that she
had to come out after three after excuse
me at three hours in the capital voting
on bills the first thing she did when
she came out of course she had to say
the Capitol Police you know didn't do
their job and it was an inside job and
they let people in introduce yourself
for those who aren't familiar with you
with you and your work okay guys uh like
I said I'm Alex Stein I'm a Blaze TV
contributor I got a show coming out in
September and uh basically what I do is
I like to highlight the most absurd
parts of our culture and jam in people's
faces because we live in a society of
political correctness where it's almost
impossible to wake people up because I
say this term a lot it's called
trauma-based Mind Control everybody's
under basically Mass formation hypnosis
so the only way in my opinion to
actually wake people up is to show them
how absurd The Narrative is it's like I
think a perfect example is Leah Thomas
you just pulled it up that Leah Thomas
has nominated for NCAA one of the year
but the fact is Leah was a man at one
point and swam on the men's team for
three years ranked 427th then is able to
take gender hormone therapy and swim
against the women and win multiple NCAA
championships so for me I think that is
very absurd and I think I feel most bad
I don't know if that's the proper
English grammar but I feel the worst for
the 17 other swimmers that had to
compete against Leah who still has male
genitalia that she's a woman and still I
believe likes women there's a lot that I
want to talk about there too because I
had a tweet about in our our UFC fighter
is allowed to take drugs to reduce their
weight so they can get into lower weight
brackets which gives them an advantage
yeah we'll get into all that stuff so uh
thanks for joining Alex it's gonna be a
blast thank you we got Mary Morgan as
well I'm back once again hello my name
is Mary I co-host pop culture crisis on
YouTube we do a live show where we cover
celebrities movies all the entertainment
news and lighthearted content that you
might not hear about on IRL and when you
Super Chat us you get to shoot money at
us it's fun great it's true Ian cross on
here Ian crossland.net I was actually on
pop culture crisis today it was hot
where we were joined by someone who
looks very much like you which was me uh
you're right uh you're wrong
and also if you haven't seen the cast
Castle Vlog today's the day if you want
to go back and see who I really am if
you don't believe me check it out it's
hot uh let's pass it on to Lydia yeah it
sounds awesome I'm very excited to be
joining Alex Stein this Prime Time on a
Friday night we're gonna take it super
easy talk about some fun stuff and hear
Alex been up to I'm stoked so people are
have started posting ghost emojis
I guess I should have gotten the NAD
earlier huh well I think I think it
might be also the lurking and the attic
thing yeah great episode it was one time
okay all right let's talk about this
first story and uh y'all have probably
seen it AOC calls out Capitol Police
after troll calls her big booty Latina
on the hill steps so that was it uh that
was you who called her your favorite big
booty latina and you were very happy and
smiling and saying you loved her and all
that stuff she got mad and so I'll I'll
just clarify right away I knew that AOC
made the statement about Capitol Police
and the Insurrection being implying it
was an inside job that there were police
inside opening the doors I just didn't
realize that she was making a point
about you specifically and so I will
walk back my statement uh what I said
earlier today was that for one I think
your culture jamming is fantastic we've
we've talked about how we want to do
culture jamming more as a marketing tool
and also to affect change and that
you've done a particularly good job of
that I don't think that calling AOC a
big booty latina solved or did anything
I was wrong it actually got her to come
out and issue a prominent statement that
January 6 was uh that people that police
officers in the building opened the door
that would not have happened were it not
for something to me seemed completely
inane and here we are I'm uh I'm
flabbergasted and you should be and it
is completely inane and let me tell you
something I am mentally insane like I
said I call myself prime time because I
am insane and this is the thing though
Tim uh even though I am an imbecile and
an idiot I want to say that I actually
planned this I I talked about this
earlier AOC constantly says that she's a
victim of sexualization she says the
people on the right do not like her
because they want to date her there was
a picture of her boyfriend now fiance in
Miami with his feet and everybody said
oh look at her gross feed you know of
course she what my point being is
for her it's all about like image and
looks and that's why people don't like
her so my thought was if I run into Elon
Omar I'm going to say I think he married
your brother is that what happened you
know I had I had stuff you know for each
congresswoman of the squad but for AOC I
said instead of like I called out Adam
kinzinger and I called him you know a
traitor and a d-bag but my point being
is when you call people out and you're
kind of like aggressive that doesn't
work that's not culture jamming that's
like being rude so in my mind I said you
know what I'm going to give AOC what she
wants I'm going to bait her and I'm
going to sexualize her and actually you
know I call this on on Sarah Gonzalez's
show on The Blaze before I said I'm
gonna call her big booty latina but I
did it I did it on purpose though the
reason why I thought
I would go to City Council meetings at
the very beginning uh you know of the
covert pandemic and I would talk
seriously you know and they wouldn't pay
attention they would look at me like I
was an idiot like a conspiracy you know
theorist which I am a tin foil hat
wearing but my point being is you
couldn't you couldn't get invoke a
response and then one of the first
meetings is we have a mayor Johnson he's
a nice guy and I said you know they're
pushing the vaccine real hard I said you
should offer free vaccines in the gay
neighborhood you should call it Eric
Johnson's free Johnson Johnson because
the gay community will love the double
entender and since you're the first
openly gay mayor of Dallas they'll
really love it he's not he's married
with kids and he was shook you know he
was just his face like a pumpkin he was
just like you know what and that's when
I kind of realized all right I have to
troll these people and my my comedic
hero is Andy Kaufman and what he did
brilliantly is he Blended the line of
reality and fiction so you couldn't tell
so my point being you know this
long-winded with AOC I said I'm going to
try to get an emotional response by
hitting on her but I want her to think
I'm serious I want her to think I
actually like her and then in her tweet
when I said you're a big booty latina
she actually ended up coming back and
trying to take some sort of selfie with
me so she liked the compliments I did in
front of her fiance who I totally she
said let's get a selfie or something
like that yes that's exactly and then
she like gave a peace sign and she did
but yet you know the narrative after was
that she wanted to deck me which is
obviously perfectly false well she she
tweeted about it and deleted it because
what was the first thing she tweeted
well she came out her staffer came out
after it happened because they're like
who is this guy and they came and took
this picture right in front of my face I
said I'm Alex Stein like I'm on the
blaze here's my business card you know
like you know I'm not trying to hide and
of course they didn't like that and then
when they figured out who I was that I'm
this right-wing troll that you know and
I'll call myself a troll you know I'm a
goblin I'm whatever whatever uh
adjective you want to call me I agree
with it my point being is when I when I
came out I admitted who I was that's
when she was triggered she just couldn't
stand it that's some right-wing guy you
know got her and she didn't want to get
got so of course her ego was just
totally shattered so she had to create
this new narrative that I said juicier
that I said ass which I never said the
video proves that and my point being in
all of this is I laid out a trap and I'm
not like I said I'm an idiot but I knew
I was going to invoke emotional response
to him but I had no idea that it would
be this big of a response that she would
make so many Instagram videos that she'd
make a post asking people questions
about it and then she has to so so uh I
stand corrected my my thought was like
you did this thing and what was the
point I understand your point now and in
fact it triggered AOC to call out the
police and the capital and directly
implicate the 1-6 committee
investigation literally saying they're
not investigating this I don't feel safe
and wow you put those pieces together
and it's you know I don't think you
expected her to indict the 1 6 Committee
in response to you trolling her on like
you know she's notorious for saying
people want to date her and things like
that and that's why I said that though
right I stand corrected i i i and so the
reason that we're seeing her response is
because she has to bury her emotional
reaction she's probably getting a ton of
heat from Democrats over what she said
about the police in January 6 and so
she's leaning as heavily into the I was
harassing as possible to dominate news
coverage to shut down the 1-6
conversation and she's right I mean I
did cross the line a little bit of of
course I hit on her but at the same time
I was very nice you know what I mean I
mean I don't care yeah I'm laughing I'm
nice I'm saying you're a big Buddha Tina
I think you're sexy even though you want
to you know abort and kill babies I
still love you you know and that was my
whole point is I try to actually be nice
because the people on the left Marjorie
Taylor green a friend of mine she's
great she says on the capitol ship
she'll get harassed or the b word the c
word all this means stuff that doesn't
have the same effect like if you start
doing that a politician's gonna put
their head down and go about their
business but as soon as you try to get
them in a trap you're either nice to
them by being you know trolling them
that's how we win the culture war is by
evoking a response
yeah well I want to know what culture
jamming means okay so culture jamming is
where you take the most absurd parts of
our culture and you jam and people's
face to bring awareness because even
people that agree with the mainstream
narrative they don't even know what the
mainstream narrative is like one video
oh go ahead oh let me just say this so
like one thing beta Awards running for
governor of Texas and so one of my
buddies Cassidy Campbell is a big
YouTube channel we you know I make all
kinds of content but we do a thing where
we'll go like fake door knocking or
really door knocking and we'll talk
about beta works like real thing how he
wants to give you know gender
reassignment surgery to seven-year-old
kids and even people that are like you
know as leftists as it gets they're kind
of like I don't know if a seven-year-old
should be on that you know so what are
you transphobic I don't know I'm
actually trans I'm gender fluid I'm
Alexandria at half the time you'll see
you can pull it up me Alex Alexandria
Stein in a bathing suit yeah we should
pull it up but my point being the
culture jamming it's just exposing the
craziest aspects of our culture here's a
really good example uh James O'Keefe
went I don't know if he personally did
but Veritas I think it might have been
Veritas or maybe it was actually just
James they went door to door and they
asked people if they were if they they
said we're a group that supports gun
control and we don't like people to you
know having guns it's dangerous do you
agree and they're like yes of course and
they said we would love it if you would
put this sign in your lawn saying proud
gun-free home and the people went
no no no I'm not doing that and they're
like why not like because you're like
inviting people to rob you and then they
go it sounds like you're saying you need
guns no no no I just I don't want that
is culture jamming those kind of stunts
that that Expose and as you said like
jam it in their face but it's just like
uh exposing the absurdities of of you
know things that are happening satire so
yeah it's like real it's activism in a
sense it's it's making a point you can
go to someone and you can be super
liminal hey X you know I will tell you
thing we need guns to stay safe we have
those rights and people are going to
argue with you about it but you go to
them and get them to tell you we will
not let people know we don't like guns
that's a secret and you're like hmm I
wonder about that right so you didn't
know that she was going to speak on one
six when you did that but what were you
hoping would happen well I just hope I
got a response just any sort of response
yeah I didn't know that she was gonna
actually take my video and download it
and re-share it you know she literally
screen recorded it and we shared it I
couldn't believe that you know it's got
millions of hits on her Twitter
um so I got I just gotta say I I feel
like you slipped on a banana peel but
pulled off a perfect backflip from 100
but see that's the thing is it's you
know you miss 100 of the shots you don't
take Wayne Gretzky Michael Scott so my
point being is you have to actually you
know go out there and try this like it
could have been a dud of course but when
you're actually on the grind and this is
for people watching at home I just want
to say you have to go try you know and
I'm a try hard for lack of a better word
and it worked not every time does it
worked but this one was gangbusters it
made me think of Kavanaugh who lately
recently had been harassed by people
standing outside a restaurant while he's
trying to eat a steak and that was the
first thing I thought was like oh okay
so this is kind of like
I don't know if he's putting it back in
someone's or at least bringing it the
thing about the Kavanaugh thing was it
wasn't televised so there's no video
evidence of it we heard about it under
the rug but the she made a statement uh
Alex after you did that Alex and Alex
hey that's pretty cool you should do a
talk show
um and that people aren't saying the the
government's not designed to protect
people and I think that's kind of true
like that they have like you were saying
they get harassed often walking up the
steps to work we know where they are we
know where they're centralized what
building they're in like that's not
secure for people to be making laws that
are angering people or could potentially
anger a lot of people well she said that
AOC tweeted that we need to make these
people uncomfortable that was exactly
her exact words so that's what I was
trying to do I wanted to make her
uncomfortable now I didn't want to cross
the line I didn't want to say like the p
word or ass I didn't say ass but I
wanted to take it to the Limit and
that's what I like to do I like to
tiptoe the line of reality and fiction
because I wanted to actually think that
I'm attracted to her and to be honest
aoc's politics are terrible but she is
very attractive I have to give her that
I'm telling you she's got a very pertain
eat derriere it's not big booty it's
actually pretty nice and
you know oh my gosh how old are you yeah
plus uh is my shampoo so I see that word
a lot I you know I
I don't I don't agree I don't understand
why though you know people would say
that to me I think she's rather horsey
when she opens her mouth but when her
mouth is closed she looks okay cute yeah
I'm not very picky that's him I mean
come on no she's got a pulse and she's
breathing right yeah well not even that
I'm just saying you know she is uh she's
in good shape she I think she checks a
lot of the boxes and I could see why she
actually got in her position she's 32
years old she's one of the most popular
congresswoman but she actually in her
Netflix documentary she basically got
casted for that you know she was
basically almost like a casting call and
so I can I can see why she got picked
almost like you get picked for a reality
show or something she has the look she
has the you know she's articulate even
though what she's saying is you know
garbage she there's a reason why she's
successful because she actually is easy
on the eyes what's the Netflix stock I
haven't heard of this yet it was
becoming AOC I believe is the name of it
and it was coming something like that
would Google it real quick I forget the
name but in that it talks about how you
know multiple multiple people for her
District you know submitted for you know
basically to get the a nomination and
she dominated but see this is another
thing we're not talking about in her own
District a guy that owns a bodega was
defending his Bodega and ended up
stabbing somebody to death that was
getting robbed and he had a 500 000 Bond
and they loaded to 250 000 so people in
New York you can rub feces on somebody
and get out of jail within 24 hours but
if you defend your Bodega you're gonna
get charged with manslaughter and you're
not even going to be able to get out of
jail so the hypocrisy in her own
District it's literally rotting like the
Big Apple it's the rotting apple right
now and she's all worried about me
saying big booty latina so her
priorities are absolutely Screwed Up the
documentary is called knock down the
house knock down the house it's for
2019. I I think she's I think the points
about her not feeling safe are
interesting because one I I'm hoping
that like when she was talking about one
six she was like clapping her hands
clapping her hands and and she looked
like tariff like just completely nervous
wreck I imagine someone in capital would
feel like that these days with this
heightened sense of security with the
economy you know inflation and things
like that and I want to help
um but also it's not it's not cool to
tell people to go make politicians
uncomfortable I mean maybe
yeah that's a very vague thing to tell I
don't I don't know I don't know I think
AOC might be right but she's just a
hypocrite and I want to say this
actually the only reason I disagree with
you is because this is part of the
left's narrative they have to be a
victim victimhood is their favorite
thing because if you play the victim
then they're not responsible for your
actions and it's like oh well if you're
poor you can steal you know so it's kind
of their victimhood mentality and AOC
she plays a victim better than anybody
in congress yet she's super successful
she's really young she's been afforded
every opportunity possible in life but
she can if she if you give her an inch
she's going to take a mile of victimhood
but this is why she's so so popular
among the millennial left she
exemplifies them given every opportunity
a bit privileged and then complaining
about it living one of the most
comfortable and comfortable lives in the
world and complaining she talks a lot
about how she came from humble
beginnings she used to be a waitress and
blah blah blah bartender you know yeah
but then ask ask ask why there are
people who are traveling thousands of
miles crawling through desert to come
here to work in the you know industrial
setting or in a chicken factory and she
was a waitress living in you know New
York or whatever in Manhattan and many
square one of the nicest neighborhoods
in New York at that famous Union Square
Restaurant right yeah and so she
probably did really well because
bartenders actually do pretty good but
it's funny because you make a point and
we talk about the Border over 108 000
drug overdose deaths this year the the
issue that we're having with fentanyl
people are literally dying young kids
opioid epidemic is one of the worst
problems that we're facing in
politicians and this is the problem that
I have with the conservative side forget
about the 80 billion dollars we're given
to Ukraine forget about Dan Crenshaw
voting for service members that aren't
vaccinated to get kicked out of the
military it doesn't matter if you have
an r or D next to your name I want them
to have an A an extra name for America
and that's the problem is that we have
all of these politicians that are run by
multi-national corporations businesses
are deciding really what's happening in
the world so it doesn't matter if you're
right or left because they do not care
about the border between Texas and
Mexico yet they're giving 80 billion
dollars to defend the border between
Russia and Ukraine and for me that
mostly makes me sick because listen I
love the gay community I love the trans
Community but if you're in the Ukraine
you cannot gay marriage is illegal if
you're transgender in the Ukraine and
you try to go to Poland they give you a
gun and they say get back on the front
line so the country that we're defending
the most with a huge majority of our
money does not even have the same
culture that we have here in America and
during pride month no less they were
giving all this money I saw and I went
to the New York City Pride and I saw
more Ukrainian Flags than I saw rainbow
well I saw more rainbow Flags but I'm
just saying I saw a lot of ukrainians in
all seriousness though there could have
been that quid pro quo there could have
been Joe Biden saying you guys gotta
ease up on the LGBT Q stuff we're going
to fund you but let's Tim this is what
makes me so mad I don't care all day
long Hunter Biden can smoke crack all
day long no serious I'm dead serious as
a matter of fact I think that makes him
endearing because everybody knows
somebody that's a drug addict what we
don't talk about we don't talk about his
business dealings in China we don't talk
about the quid pro quid pro quo Joe
talking about giving a billion dollars
making sure they had the right people in
power in the Ukraine and now we're
fighting a proxy war we're fighting a
war by proxy killing young people over
what over decisions made by a crackhead
president by the president's crackhead
son that it gets that gets no media
attention but they're going to give you
the prostitutes all day long they're
going to give you the crack pipe all day
long like you should talk about the quid
pro quo stuff like I don't shut up about
it no but but what I'm saying is your
frustration about hey I'm so mad that
you know he's the big booty uh Latina is
a head story because the real story is
that January 6 the Capitol Police let
people in and that's obvious because
people couldn't get in they didn't have
a key to get into the door but it's the
same thing the crazy thing is there's
that video going viral right now where
the window was smashed out they still
can't get in because it's maglocked and
then these guys look up at someone one
in point and then someone releases the
maglock and that could have been an
insurrectionist whatever you want to
call them maybe someone broke in found
the mag lock release and they said press
it or maybe it was a cop because we did
see other cops open the door directly we
saw other cops taking selfies so I'm
with AOC on that one I want the
investigation too no thousand percent we
want the investigation obviously she
thinks the outcome will be different
from what the right thinks it will be
but I don't think that's relevant I
think the question is what happened and
we look at January 6 you know obviously
there's some people one of my very good
friends Luke Coffey you know he has a
GoFundMe he's actually being charged
with assaulting a police officer he's
actually kind of well known he's the
crutch guy and he held a Karachi he
found a crutch on the ground and did he
kind of you know put it against her
right Shields and now he's being charged
with assaulting a cop and let me tell
you something the guy's a 37 year old
young nice kid that you know felt you
know that there was an injustice even
though it was the 37 year old young kid
I'm just saying he's a young middle-aged
man middle-aged man but I'm just saying
he's not he's not built for excuse me
he's not built for federal prison is my
point being I think he would be young
for prison but it was the most Fair
election the best election ever Joe
Biden got 81 million votes I just want
to put that on record my point being
there is people there that loved our
country very much and now they're being
labeled as a domestic terrorist they're
saying it's worse than 9 11. and for me
I look back at our government's track
record the same people that said we had
weapons of mass destruction which we
didn't are the same people that saying
American citizens that love our country
the most are terrorists so the
government's going to lie to you to
create a narrative that's not true I'll
tell you what I think I think the people
that write it I think the people that
were fighting with cops even pushing on
the cops that's bad and there's got to
be uh some accountability there that's
fair but
um I think that when Trump gets in
office in 2024 well in 2025 blanket
pardon across the board oh hey [ __ ] but
do you think Trump will beat DeSantis I
don't know I don't know but I'm saying
like I'm not saying that will happen I'm
just saying if Trump order since it gets
in I think without condemning uh well
actually no with a little condemnation
but with recognizing the threat this
country faces through the massive divide
I think you've got to get these people
out yeah um you've talked about it
before which is rebellious Rebellion
yeah John Hancock pardoned a bunch of
the farmers that had rebelled because
they were being overtaxed they didn't
have the money they were just back from
the revolution Soldiers with their
fortunes depleted and then they were
getting imprisoned because they didn't
have the money still that they didn't
have and they just surrounded the
courthouse refused to let the people the
judges act and they there was jail
sentences and stuff and then Hancock
came and was like no no we're forming a
union you're pardoned everyone's
pardoned well let's talk about let's
talk about Trump because everybody loves
Trump and I love the Trump that calls
Little Marco Rubio or you know I love
the Trump what's he gonna say about
DeSantis I think I think Hancock didn't
pardon he pardoned everyone except for
like three people or two people but my
point being is listen Trump I think had
11 days in office where he could have
pardoned some people you look at Trump
with Julian Assange who the Wikileaks
basically gave him the 2016 election yet
he doesn't get a pardon you know uh
Kodak Black gets one I'm not saying that
Kodak Black you know good rapper not
saying you shouldn't get one but I think
Trump has a serious you know priority
issue I I just I just
I gotta point this out never in my life
growing up as like in the 2000s into
Occupy Wall Street and after for several
years after did I think that at one
point in my life I would be sitting
across the table from a conservative I
would say yes yeah well I'm kind of down
the middle but yeah suit wearing Guy
arguing that the Republican president
should have pardoned Julian Assange
because 10 years ago the left loved
Assange and now they leave him hanging
out to dry they they leave him to rot
Tim you made your bones oh excuse me
well you say what you're going to say I
was going to say Trump is the reason
they're trying to uh extradite Julian
Assange too I think Trump wanted Julian
Assange because Julian knows things
about the DNC and Trump wanted that and
so now he's being handed off to Joe
Biden which is extremely dangerous but
anyway well let's talk about occupy
because I know that was you know a huge
thing for you those people were very
anti-establishment then those people
were anti-banks now these people love
Pfizer they love Banks they love
Halliburton so it just shows you these
people are under what I call Mass
formation hypnosis they don't even know
whose side to be on I agree and this
wasn't that long ago like you said in
2008 when we had the financial crash
people out there protesting for what I
agree is I'm anti-establishment I'm not
right or left I just don't like the
establishment I think that the system is
just terrible and the people in power
once they get in power I talk about the
multinational corporations all they care
about is their political action
committee they care about the money that
they're getting donated it's like you
look at Apple you know Apple freaking in
in China at their Foxconn factories
instead of paying their employees more
they have suicide Nets because so many
employees are jumping off the roof but
instead of paying them a little more
they make stronger Nets they make bigger
Nets so we have a priority issue because
it's the globalization of America and
that's why I'm an American first guy
because I care about America I want to
actually put America in the Forefront
but if you say you're a nationalist or
if you have an American flag in your
yard that's a hate symbol your right
wing now yeah exactly conservative and
I'm altered I'm considered alt right
because I love America and that's not
how it should be but they create a
narrative that America is bad bad yet
nearly a hundred thousand people even
more than that illegally cross into our
country every month so go figure if it's
such a racist Place why why does
everyone want to immigrate here man you
you hit the nail on the head uh right
there I completely agree
um I never really cared all that much
for the left the right you know that
idea is it was always just like the
machine is broken it is unjust it is
corrupt it is manipulative and so that
is for me especially it starts with the
media because the media is lying to
people and they just go along with it so
that is that's really what got me here
early on in my career I wasn't talking
that much about Democrats Republicans it
was the media in their lives
well as time goes on you start to
realize they're lying to benefit the
uniparty which morphed into the
Democrats when Trump took over and then
you get a narrative the Democratic party
is the party of the establishment
wealthy Elites the media props them up
the Lincoln project and the neocons
joined the Democrats after Trump took
over half the Republican party is
extremely bad the other third is really
bad as a small handful of them that are
okay for me I'm like Thomas Massey's
cool Rand Paul I like Dr Taylor green is
great and the rest of them there's a few
others that are that are doing a
decently good job but the machine itself
is dominated by the uniparty and it's
just corrupt I don't care about how many
how much taxes you want to take that's
that's answer layer it's after the fact
we can have a conversation about that
for the time being it's corrupt people
lying cheating and stealing and
destroying the country I wonder if it's
the media is manipulating the
politicians I'm sure it's happening on
some level or if they're all colluding
or if the politicians are making the
media act that way but I think like like
Alexandria Cortez she didn't ever
mention I've never heard her mention the
one won six cops letting people in on
one six like I've never heard her
mention that until a couple days ago and
it's been two years of people in
solitary did she not hear about it
through are they that insulated like
that it's hard to think that people
could be so insulated that they don't
see what I see but we're I've spent a
lot of my time looking at a lot of
things from the outside I think when
you're in that DC environment you may
they may actually be very intentionally
insulated no Ian I deserve all the
credit I broke her you know I broke her
I created an emotional she thinks that
getting called a big booty latina is the
same gravity as one six a hundred
percent she thinks the cops you know are
basically you know they since they
didn't arrest me which they did they did
she complained five times she said in
her own tweet and the cops did come and
they id'd me I gave my ID I said am I
under arrest am I being detained they
said no and I was able to walk away and
her watching me walk away I know made
her so mad that she's like I hate these
Capital police oh my God they let the
writers in so um
what was interesting is that she then
she must have known about it for a while
oh come on Ian everybody knows about
this and listen she's the same person
that said she was afraid of her life yet
she was a mile away and at the same time
even if every single rioter went in do
they really think that they were going
to be able to you know even do any sort
of legislation come on she so this is a
narrative that for some reason has even
been difficult to uh permeate the right
when AOC said Chief was scared when they
came and knocked on her door she wasn't
just not in the capital she fabricated
the story outright oh politician lied
what this is a tough one I thought if we
claimed to be in one of the bathrooms
hiding in her office let me let me break
this down for you because I will tell
the story every chance I get AOC did an
Instagram video it's about 45 minutes
long where she's sad she's in her office
and she hears a knock knock and she got
scared thinking it's them they've gotten
here what do I do and they said go hide
in the bathroom and I did and the door
opens and it's a police officer going or
it's a man going where is she
where is she
and she's like I she said she thought
she was gonna die turns out as a police
officer evacuating her what she doesn't
tell you although she kind of does is
that she's in there pooping no is that
that happened I believe one full hour
before the barricades were breached at
the front of the building meaning no one
knew anyone was going to get into the
capital
Chevrolet ABS he knew right well AOC
claimed she thought they had made it to
her her off her office how does that
make sense nobody was in the building
nobody knew they were running in the
building and if AOC knew they were going
to breach the building why didn't she
report it weird questions there right
the media tried defending her saying yes
she wasn't in the capital she was in her
office but there are tunnels that
connect the capital to her office that
explains it I had a guy from The
Huffington Post tell me that I was wrong
when I tweeted her story didn't make
sense and he DMS me and then I pulled
the timeline and he responds and in
private DM going like oh oh you're right
she when she claimed that she thought
they got to her office and she was gonna
die no one had even attempted to breach
the Capitol building
she made the story up it was like a full
hour before the barricades even moved
something like that and then they made
their way to the front of the Capitol
but AOC had no idea what's going to
happen she fabricated the story after
the fact and people bought it believed
it they still do this I've been thinking
lately no matter how emotional I am
about something no matter how strongly I
feel about something it doesn't make it
more or less right like
so getting crying saying it's real
doesn't make it more or less
manipulation yeah you have to be
emotional and and I don't want to get
too conspiratorial but it kind of sounds
like you remember how Larry Silverstein
during 9 11 you know he usually has
breakfast there and he happened to be
having a uh a little doctor's
appointment for his skin I'm just saying
you know it's not a surprise that these
people probably do have prior knowledge
to stuff that's going to happen and we
talk about Ray Epps because I know you
want to expose that but literally he's
on camera saying we need to have an
Insurrection we need to go inside yet
you look at the mainstream media New
York Times Adam kinzinger if they're
running cover for him they are running
cover then you know what the truth is
you know that he's involved and they're
protecting him but but let me say this
real quick because we know about the
Mockingbird media we know the government
admits that they have literally
intelligence and every radio television
film every form of media that we have so
it would be impossible
for him to be this protected by the
media if he wasn't in well it's well
that he wasn't in on it and that they
just don't know it is not possible I'm
just you're talking about probability in
this instance I really doubt that
probability I think the first thing I
say about raps is we just don't know
the second thing I'll say is what we do
know is that he called for storming the
capital and he's not being criminally
charged he's being protected he's being
he's been protected by the media and by
and Adam kings are kinsinger defended
him online the question then becomes why
we have no evidence to explain what
their motivation is we can only surmise
at the very least a plausible minimum
non-conspiratorial responses right apps
may have been the first guy the feds
went after because he was on the live
stream saying it they made it may have
been looking at him right away the deal
made a deal with him immediately it
could have been
the night before he's on a live stream
telling people to storm the capital I
imagine this before anything happened
feds could have went right to him in the
hotel and said you're going to wear a
wire you're going to give us names and
you work for us now as a CI and that's
why after the fact you don't see him
getting charged not that he's a federal
agent but that he may have been an
informant after the fact now that's a
minimum maybe there's something else
Beyond this
I just don't know what I do know is it
is very strange that they're putting
people in solitary they're charging them
with seditious conspiracy but the guy
who's literally on camera telling people
to do it telling them how to do it
hasn't been charged Tim mag a granny
there's a grandma in there with their
little flag and she's a hardened
criminal they actually think she's going
to be able to overthrow the government
the photo of the one with the little
flag was from I think Madison but there
is currently a 69 year old cancer
patient cancer patient going to a
60-year 60 to 60 years 60 days in jail
you know why they're just passing you
know why the judge said that because the
judge had let somebody else off and they
went on Fox News and didn't show remorse
but in the courtroom they did show
remorse so because of somebody else's
conviction she got uh 60 days 69 year
old cancer patient so that's where we're
at that's that's why I'm saying
so the funny thing is and I'm glad AOC
uh
said the doors are open by police
because that is a huge huge powerful
political point and uh uh I will say I
am shocked that it is the result of you
calling AOC a big booty latina well we
don't know it's the result no it is it
is it is and reality is Stranger Than
Fiction Tim you have to realize that
this is important because there are many
people like the 69 year old cancer
patient uh Pamela Hemphill by that it
was miss him I don't know her specific
story but I really doubt the 69 year old
cancer patient was fighting with police
officers
she's probably one of the people who saw
the door opened and walked in very
casually when she was on medical
marijuana probably so she didn't even
know where she was at I'm just I'm just
kidding because the police should open
the door in more than one location
police at the Capitol Building opened
the doors there's even an instance where
the police fanned people in and a man
was acquitted on all counts because he
showed a video to the judge of him being
motioned in by the officer so he was
acquitted for that
though there were there was more than
one door that was open there was an
instance where the cop said he respected
what the people were doing and there's
instances where the cops took selfies
with people so now this woman is going
to jail for 60 days after she was
potentially invited in or some people
were
these people need to be pardoned across
the board for this ridiculous
misdemeanor stuff and it is powerful
extremely powerful now that aocs at the
doors were opened that needs that clip
needs to be I I don't know should I take
that clip and I should I buy TV
commercials honestly hey but let's not
forget Ashley Babbitt probably let in by
a capital police officer gets shot and
murdered and she was a veteran she's
somebody that loved their country so
much and she just gets thrown under the
rug as some evil person so not only did
you know these people get let in but
some people got murdered
I I think maybe we do a um I have to
figure out how to do it there's a lot of
things I want to do that never happen
unfortunate which I don't like bringing
it I don't like saying we want to do
things if we don't have a means to
actually get it done yeah but I would
love to see a commercial where it's like
Alexandria ocasio-cortez says that they
were cops and other people who opened
the doors to let that in on January 6
and has called for an investigation
we agree with Alexandria Cortez support
the calls for an investigation into who
opened the doors at the Capitol building
can you play that video let me see if uh
she's got to be regretting this point
right or not I think she's being very
serious and it is disturbing
the aggregation may have let people lose
and that that people will be in solid if
police let people in and those people
that were let in are in solitary
confinement it is inane it is it is
abjunct to American democracy I just
want to say real quick my video talking
about AOC and the big booty thing was
age restricted on YouTube what the video
where I talked about big booty latina
and all that stuff they age restricted
adult term maybe
because don't babies no well so here's
here's here's the video Club let's uh
wait on this time I'm gonna make sure we
have the audio set properly before I
press play like antifa and that there
were actual officers working with this
and we never got to the bottom of that
and we never got any answers about that
and then to this day we're just supposed
to pretend that that never happened we
have no idea what happened to the people
on the inside who were very clearly
sympathetic with what was going on and
opening the doors wide open for that and
where I'm supposed to sit here and
pretend like none of that ever happened
and then right afterwards you have a
massive you know you just have this idea
that throwing money at that problem is
going to make it go away we could bring
some building accountability and so this
is this is where these things are
breaking down we're not safe and it's
not just about member of Congress not
being safe staff workers aren't safe the
janitors aren't safe like we need to get
to the bottom of that yes so I'd love to
get like a commercial of like a 60 year
old man being like Alexandria
ocasio-cortez says people on the inside
open the door this is what happened when
you talk to her when you approach her on
the steps she was with a capitol police
officer that didn't get in your away and
stop you and now she's questioning is
that guy is that guy and it's and she's
wondering if they're like traders in the
building whatever her reasoning is it's
important that we find out if people let
people into the building because those
people are in solitary confinement right
now and that's Ian do you think they had
a key I'm
think they opened I saw a magnetic lock
on the door get opened I saw the video
of a cop look at it I don't know right
someone off camera yep and it was a
police officer that like looked up and
then you think these these these dudes
who are like trying to break a window to
get in know where the mag release is and
you know you don't think there's some of
those cops that probably were
sympathetic to what was happening sure I
mean she's obviously correct I don't I
don't care what the end result is maybe
the end result is like members of
Congress were in on it good whatever
let's have an investigation and who
opened those doors I'm if there were
members of Congress that were
orchestrating the opening of the door to
bring people in to disrupt this then we
should find out who did that and why I
think all of these bumbling daughters
these old people the magamemas who just
saw a clear path and cops waving them in
who walked in and now have their lives
destroyed should be pardoned those
people should have never been charged
that was a fault of capital police in
the government
I want an investigation of the cops to
open the doors if they didn't open the
doors this wouldn't have happened well
in your bestie Joe Rogan talks about one
of his favorite things that Alex Jones
did is he exposed to WTO about in I
believe in Seattle where there were
agent provocateurs who stayed in a
building and you know basically they
were all wearing the same boots and and
agent provocateurs exist now you're
going to say oh none of them were on
January 6th we have evidence of people
using agent provocateurs to make a riot
look bad that's that's a Playbook it's
kind of similar to operation Northwoods
which was you know it was a Declassified
thing where they're going to take planes
and fly them into buildings or in the
Cuban Missile Crisis and the 911 was
kind of similar to that but what I'm
saying is if you do not think the
government has classified levels of
information and it's creating a
narrative by using their own military
CIA FBI whatever you want to call it
alphabet agencies in order to make
things look worse than they really are
you know you might be a conspiracy
because it's a reason to get more
funding for more security apparatus to
grow the security it's a false flag
attack guys and this is a false flag
attack Playbook I mean you know I could
be wrong I'm not saying that I know
everything but just all of the evidence
when we see Ray apps and we see the way
the media is protecting them it's hard
for me to imagine that this was all just
accidental yeah it could be a hybrid of
like people getting angry and going to
the Capitol storming ah and people
trying to benefit off it by making it
come out worse as a result so it could
be both I think if it is uh in that vein
of false flag it's more so that they
allowed it to happen and that's why
there's video of police officers not
intervening there's a guy walking up to
cops being like why won't you stop this
and the cops are like we don't care it's
it explains more so why there was no
National Guard no heavy police presence
why their client like Trump said he
wanted the National Guard there and they
rejected it so if I'll put it this way
on 5 29 the left insurrected they tried
to they did tear down the barricades of
the White House they set fire to St
John's Church and the and the guard post
they forced the president into a bunker
if the police there stood down and they
tore the fences down or breached the
White House
there would not be a 1-6 Donald Trump
would be president Donald Trump there
would have been a major statement there
would have been far left extremists have
breached the White House Americans would
have been terrified they would have said
this is insane and then the conversation
would have been the police saying things
like we stood down because we did not
want to hurt people and we didn't know
how to react to this level but what
happens is the police go out
do their job and clear that clear the
space and the and the response from the
media and the Democrats was to
investigate the police over it they said
the Capitol Police should be
investigated for attacking protesters
that's how it went down on January 6
because the police let everyone do
everything it's oh oh geez the police
were the poor victims and these are the
bad guys it's it's the very it's the
very typical I'm the victim narrative
that that is manipul is used to
manipulate people to gain power and it
is potentially possible that that's that
was happening like a cops like uh
there's 700 screaming people I'm not
getting involved are you kidding me like
that could probably also have been part
of it I wouldn't you know I wouldn't get
I mean what are you gonna do you get
mobbed if that happens let's talk about
the Summer of Love 2020 rip George Floyd
he's one of the greatest Americans of
all time one of my favorite actors but
what I'm saying is uh George Floyd they
literally burned down multiple cities
and Kamala Harris donated to their bail
bond fund if that is not a false flag so
that's basically encouraging people to
cause as much damage knowing you're
going to get a get out a free jail card
how much more evidence do you need that
they like the protesting they want this
to happen so the fact that they would
convince trumpers to go and do some sort
of insurrection I wouldn't put him past
him and we talk about this how I do in
my show MK Ultra and you think about it
doesn't have to be the 1984 you know
make you watch a video with your eyes
wide open you can propagandize people
with just the mainstream media with just
commercials with just you know basically
creating a narrative you can Target
someone's Facebook Twitter or Instagram
to only see certain things that will
drive them insane and this is the crazy
thing people need to realize about these
platforms
Facebook did an experiment on people
years ago where they only showed them
negative content to see how their posts
would change and how they would behave
well you know it sees a dilation of your
pupil when you press a like or you know
you give it access to the rear phrase
they admit this it gives you give access
to the front-facing camera and it will
actually measure the dilation of your
pupil if you hit a like or you that's
that's why they created the multiple
emojis in order to see the different
dilation levels of the eyeballs with a
different response so we know that
Facebook was experimenting on people
they were showing some people only happy
content people got happy they showed
people negative angry content people get
angry they could choose Facebook knows
this so they can see they can they can
probably seek out we we're looking for
angry people they find 50 angry people
okay we want the 50 angry people in this
particular area
now we're only we're going to make sure
the only thing they see is the
government doing things that violate
people's rights then these people start
getting anger and anger every day seeing
this being like what is happening what
is happening what is my life and then
they get a message from somebody or they
comment on the post and there's another
person that happens to be a fad being
like Oh yeah I am also angry why don't
you come here and plan something and
then the feds come in and we got you or
they screw up and then someone actually
gets out and does something and they're
like oops well better arrest them what's
what's the FBI's favorite narrative
after a school shooting well he was on
our radar he was on our radar he was on
a reader but we just you know he wasn't
a big enough on a Raider well proving
the uh uh the red flag laws don't do
anything yeah well in Dan Crenshaw voted
for that in the state like Texas where
what happened to that guy because like
he said he's bought and sold by these
you know multinational corporations and
he doesn't care about America because
he's the same guy that you know he lost
his eye in the war but he wants to send
more people to fight for the war and I'm
a conflict interventionalist I hate the
war I don't think there's any necessary
reason to kill other people even if you
have the biggest conflict in the world
you have the biggest disagreement we are
human beings that's what separates us
from the animals we should be able to
come to agreement like humans what about
with communists why don't you think we
should fight communism no but what if
the Communists are subverting your
country and killing people and
sterilizing kids and you're like I'm the
guy that stands in front of the tank and
gets ran over I mean that's honestly how
I feel I I hear you um I agree for the
most part I think the foreign
intervention is is typically a huge
mistake but I'm not so naive as to to
not understand the argument made by
neocons right there's a power vacuum in
the Middle East if we don't do it China
moves in China's moving into Afghanistan
they're going to seize up all that
lithium it's going to empower a really
really awful country and so
I don't think the US's argument for what
they do is justifying it but I
understand the point they're making and
not wanting China they said weapons of
mass destruction we have enough oil and
gas reserves in Texas alone to for
America so the real reason is that what
the U.S wanted justification to do to
dominate other regions to prevent a
multi-polar world no it's for the
military-industrial complex I mean I'm
not saying you're wrong I'm just saying
there's a it's a nuanced situation you
look that's a component of it yeah but
it's a big component quite possibly the
biggest but I don't think it is just
that simple it is true that China is
gaining ground expanding in South Africa
uh in South America and uh and Africa
continent-wise and as the U.S starts to
recede they start expanding and then
we're going to have to contend with a
multi-polar world where you have a China
as a serious Contender for you know as a
world power yeah but Tim you look at
Barack Obama he won the Nobel Peace
Prize and all he had to do is drop a
drone strike every 20 minutes for eight
years he killed people at weddings he
killed children I think it's wrong so
that's that to me if you kill it's like
why I don't really like the death
penalty because if you if you you know
use capital punishment you murder one
innocent person which you've done most
agree it makes it necessarily the whole
system I completely agree on all of that
yeah this is why I opposed the death
penalty but but it's funny you say China
because they say it's our biggest threat
and I agree that they are a threat
because I think it's the the Chinese
fentanyl that they can add a molecule to
it that they're flooding through the
Border like I said earlier we have a
massive opioid epidemic but China they
rely on us like we rely on them so it's
almost a copacetic relationship one
cannot exist without the other at this
point so they want to give us the
impression that we're always going to be
fighting with them but their economies
dying right now our economy is dying so
what I'm saying is unless we come
together and build each other up we're
not going to make it so by killing each
other I think that just makes the
problem worse we actually have to come
to some sort of agreement like the
donbus region of Ukraine and if Russia
wants a little land give them some land
I don't even care I don't want young
children to die call me a conflict
intervention just call me excuse my
language you know wussy whatever that's
how I am you did see Hitler wanted a
little land in the Sudan land when they
and they gave it to him and then you saw
yeah but everybody's Hitler I mean come
on in you know what I mean that that's
that's what appeasement's not always but
it's not it's not it's not about Hitler
and using the Nazi analogy it's about a
conflict in which we said we'll give you
land and the person said Okay I want
more yeah give a mouse cookie you gotta
give him milk I've been thinking about I
could have taken a neutral stance on the
war machine I I was picturing having a
conversation with Hillary Clinton last
night and just like where she's just
totally candid like yeah whatever and
I'm like okay so what's up dude and
she's like Ian we're running the
military the the military machine this
is it this is the war machine we have it
right now it's since the dawn of man
there has been a war machine and now
it's American and we have to use it if
we don't someone else will take it Ian
let me say this there's a little country
called Libya and Muammar Gaddafi was
universally loved by his people even
though say there's a different narrative
let me tell you something Libya is the
only place in the world right now that
has slave auctions happens today what
did Hillary Clinton say we came we saw
he died so Hillary Clinton going into
countries
doing the war machine is the only place
on Earth where you can go buy a slave in
2022. I could go there right now and go
buy me a slave think about that that's
all because of Hillary who her husband
flew on Jeffrey Epstein's plane 26 times
without Secret Service and Elaine
Maxwell the only person to get 20 years
in prison for sex trafficking children
to no one so let me tell you something
these people making the decision do not
care about children they do not care
kill or care about killing babies and
they definitely don't care about black
people if there's a slave trade going on
in a country that they destabilize they
don't they don't they care they care to
the point where it's utilitarian
decision making because destruction and
moving resources around is a utilitarian
function it doesn't matter who's getting
them enough people for the banks for the
stabilization of the system I don't
think Hillary Clinton you know I'm sorry
Ian like you can make the argument about
some Global Elites that they think
they're doing the right thing and that
the needs of the many outweigh the needs
of the few but Hillary Clinton is not
that she is she she ran the war machine
for a while but what I mean is the
accounts of Hillary Clinton are that
she's like literally the devil that
she's not trying to help you get into
the position of American commander and
not be the devil you're just going to
destroy what's wrong listen what I'm
saying is there are some world leaders
that you could make an argument they're
utilitarians who think they're doing
good Hillary Clinton is not one of those
people she is a demon who wants to cause
Mass I mean she's just a mom but she got
no she's not just she's not Justin when
she laughed about that that child who
was raped this woman is evil when was
that when she was younger she was it was
she interning for a lawyer and then she
got off into the rapist and that's fine
everybody deserves defense I agree with
that she she laughed about how she got
him oh he got away with it I vaguely
remember that yeah well what makes
someone like that so uh narcissistic
sociopathy there's a story that she was
on uh like I think she was on a U.S Air
Force plane and there are ranking
officers who are like engineers and
pilots and she holds up a wine glass
that's empty and goes
and they're looking around like what and
she was I think what's happening like
like these these Military Officers need
to pour her wine for it that was a story
there was a book about it there's
numerous stories about how she treats
people with disdain she disparages
people she treats them like garbage
insects yeah so my point stuff aside the
system is insanely destructive that we
live in and I was like well we've never
really done a genocide in the United
States and I was like the native
population oh yeah we we genocided 90
Trails yeah like so this whole system is
about destroying people and things
taking land getting your food getting
for your people and like okay accept
that if you want to talk about it at
least you know so so the issue here is
that's the history of the world of all
people and now the power is in the
United States hands and that's why like
do we want it out of the United States
it's like I like your idea of a peaceful
union of people but we need to make sure
they have enough food and resources and
water so let's sell all the farmland to
Bill Gates but no but let me tell you
this so in you know RFP Norm McDonald
probably one of the best comedians but
he when he was on SNL when he was doing
Weekend Update he's one of the funniest
guys ever he would go after Hillary for
Vince Foster Vince Foster I believe was
the chief of staff for Bill and he's a
guy that died in the park I think it was
like two gunshots to their head so I'm
not even talking about the Clinton Body
Count I'm just saying where there's
smoke there's fire for I could defend
AOC a million times over then before I
would defend Hillary Clinton just based
on like you said the laughing at the
rape of a child you look at all the
conspiracy behind her so to defend these
elitists because there's it's like a
multi-level marketing scheme Ian no one
person or a few people benefit from all
of our suffering it's very
compartmentalized you want to you kind
of want to be you know you want it in
your head you want to think that oh the
system's fair but that's called
cognitive dissonance thinking the
government has your back when in reality
the government is going to pee on you
all day and tell you it's raining I
don't think it's fair can we highly
we're going to pull this up we're gonna
do the segment on this one we're gonna
do it Norm Macdonald is the best oh
Vince Foster Deputy White House counsel
Have You Ever Seen The Norm Macdonald on
The View Bill Clinton murdered a guy oh
boy let's uh Barbara Walters is look at
her
loves to see him oh yeah that's a little
desperate in it
let's jump to uh a lie or a crook murder
or anything like that I love George Bush
man he's a good man decent you know none
of it falls
yeah he's uh you know he's not a a lie
or a crook murderer or anything like
that so it'd be good to get the see I I
don't I think we should get the homicide
out of the White House and get like a a
fresh start because we don't want any
more murderers I think we should just go
on to the next question
wow
accusations
let's just go on to the next one oh all
right this is not my week wait he pushes
it a little longer oh it's not mine
either and I'm being very nice okay
be a good boy now Norm do you never hear
that no listen we don't need
this is not the place to make those
accusations and you're supposed to be
funny he is
thought it was a matter of Records
[Laughter]
okay let me do this okay I'll tell you
what the matter of record you will not
be invited back if you don't shut up all
right
football all right Matt manslaughter
that
um
hello
oh yeah oh no uh the thing is this there
uh you know Matt Strauss yeah the
producer the producer he told me it
would be funny he said like why don't
you carry a cell phone on and then let
it ring and then pretend like there's a
guy on it
yeah it's a thing pretend
is that is that's the end but it's funny
that you make a really good point in
there though she says let's talk about
football because listen I used to love
professional sports but that is what
distracts us Tim from really what's
going on they give us bread and circuses
oh my gosh I'm gonna drink my beer on
Sunday and watch the Dallas Cowboys lose
for the you know 100th straight you know
when I was younger I was very much like
I wish people stopped focusing on the on
the sports and paid attention to
politics but now that really really dumb
people are treating politics like sports
I'm like maybe that was a bad idea yeah
but Sports listen LeBron James she's
never read past the first page of a book
no he notes and he gets political and he
comes out and he campaigns and it's like
stop please please stop you don't read
you know what you're talking about but
who does he defend the most China so
right my point being is sports are great
it's part of American culture baseball
yeah we got it Jane I don't do good
Impressions but what I'm saying is
sports are important I think for the
Youth it gives them some sort of
structure I think you know skateboarding
anything I'm saying any athletic prowess
is good for young people instead of
sitting and just playing a game
um speaking of I want to actually make
this point this is what I Envision the
future is I actually believe believe
that we're going to have some sort of
Vanilla Sky
um Matrix future where people are going
to be so their lives are going to be so
you know tumultuous outside of it that
they're going to actually convince
people to plug into what is called the
metaverse very similar to The Matrix and
they're going to say listen we're going
to intubate you and in the metaverse Ian
you're going to have you know a 10 inch
you know what you're gonna you know
you're gonna have you're gonna be dating
a supermodel all the people so so it'll
be smaller yeah
okay but what I'm saying is uh uh my
point being is that you're gonna have a
beautiful supermodel life and instead of
living you're 72 years on average here
on Earth you're gonna live for a
thousand years and you can look this up
they're actually talking about prison
sentences for people where you can make
somebody think that they had a 10 000
years sins in a week you could be in it
right now you could you know you're like
wondering why your life sucks while
you're poor and it's like you're in jail
you know but what my point being is is
the you know the technology that they're
gonna have and there's a thing called
The Uncanny Valley and actually uh I
forget the exact term for it but like a
t Verizon what they do is they try to
actually get like when you call a um a
robot basically to try to get customer
service they're trying to create
technology where you can't tell that
you're talking to a robot and they can't
do it if they're ever tested they can't
do it because there's a thing called
uncanny valley where they can't make it
exactly like a human it's not going to
have the same speech pattern it's you're
always someday they will though maybe
well you say that you say that and
that's why I don't necessarily think
they will because I think it's almost
impossible and the reason why is you say
oh artificial intelligence will be able
to create that really artificial
intelligence just takes basically it can
make future decisions for you based on
past decisions but the idea that it can
be you and me there's some sort of
uniqueness about us that I do believe is
impossible to recreate and I think that
could be our soul personally but I just
think it's almost impossible there's
artificial emotion there's a there's a
movie where they invent there's like eye
drops was it a movie or a show I don't
know and then it simulates an experience
and so like this woman like puts the eye
drops in and then in the span of like 10
minutes she spends a weekend in Aspen
and then her business partners like I've
got a better use for this prison
sentences that's nice and then she's
like you can't do this and then they
fight and then she like pins him down
and she like you know he like puts the
drop in her eye and forces her into like
a thousand year prison chamber it's like
all psychological so there's literally
no way to escape you could also make it
where it it it happened like you
experience 10 seconds in the metaverse
but when you come out it's 70 years
later in real you'd be dead though yeah
that's a way to like comatose people so
here's a thought Here's a thought what
if your life your mundane life where
you're trying to live right you're
trying to be a good person you're
resisting all this woke coming some
garbage in reality you are a woke
communist who was involved in some
antifa violence and so you were
sentenced to Rehabilitation where they
make you live a life on the other side
to experience violence from them so that
when you finally come out you're like I
can't stand those people and then you're
like whoa I was those people now I get
it and you've been reprogrammed well
it's like Inception but I'll be honest
you know we talk about the prison
industry and you know a lot of people on
the conservative side will say systemic
racism doesn't exist but for me I do
believe it exists because you look at a
lot of the non-violent drug offenders in
jail are African-American or black so I
do think we have a prison system a
private prison industry in America
that's a huge business it goes along
with a lot of the military-industrial
complex the pharmaceutical industrial
complex once again it's the American
people being sold out to corporations to
make money this guy's a liberal it kind
of and I I wouldn't be against universal
healthcare in some form not necessarily
the way they want on it but I'm saying
at least less taxes there should be a
way where people are so afraid Tim I
know a lot of people I'm in the bail
bond business we actually get people out
of jail so that's why prison reform is a
big deal to me but I know people that
are afraid to call an ambulance and will
take an Uber to the hospital because
they can't afford an ambulance so I'm
not saying Canada system's good I don't
know what system I'm not that smart
right dude I took I took a taxi to the
hospital once exactly see right there I
call the cab I I had a I had a kidney
stone and it hit me like all of a sudden
out of nowhere crippling pain and I was
like quick call Green Cab Uber think
about that Tim you should have been able
to call an ambulance I agree completely
and uh I'm like dude 50 bucks in an Uber
or 500 an ambulance it's more than 500
right yeah I don't like um chronic uh
Healthcare Universal Health Care for
chronic stuff like someone eats too much
Universal Health you know it's gonna
suck but I just feel like it's a better
alternative a kid breaks his arm instead
of some mom being like yeah what am I
going to pay for emergency Health Care
Emergency
that's what chronic is where it's like
they don't stop eating poison and then
they get sick it's like dude you did
that to yourself I'm not here but I
gotta say this point why is why is
diabetes medicine you know 170 in
America but in Mexico it's five dollars
why is Dental Care the same thing why is
it that all of my and cap friends are
like oh I gotta get my teeth fixed I'll
be flying uh you know uh to Mexico City
or Costa Rica Costa Rica especially they
argue that it's cosmetic not MediCal
right that's it's nonsense and here's
the crazy thing too in Mexico and in
Costa Rica they do this thing where
after they do the work on your teeth
they take your own blood and and put it
over the the damaged part of your mouth
from the surgery and it heals way faster
yeah your own blood because it it heals
you right they don't do that here as far
as I know I was talking to somebody and
I looked it up and I was like if you go
to Costa Rica it's like a tenth of the
price with better treatment I'm like
that doesn't make sense Tim what does it
make sense is that we prescribe
antidepressants to people that are
suicidal that makes you more suicidal I
know
freaking side effect in the commercial
you'll see somebody dancing in a field
oh may cause suicidal idolization or
idealization it's like what you're
giving it to people that are suicidal I
mean isn't that counter-intuitive yeah
the better dude they want to get you on
it too the sooner you get on the
antidepressants the better it'll heal
you but as soon as they came out mental
health issues skyrocketed what are the
chances I can accept that we have that
there is a war machine that the United
States is in in control of but what
happens when corporations try to take
control of it and and poison and subdue
the population through other kinds of
means non-violent means like like
psychedelic psychoactive that's not cool
I don't want to lose control of the War
Machine by Point by going after our own
people false Flags pharmaceutical
induction like that I'm not comfortable
with I'm down to hold on to the military
and make sure that we have a stable
planet where the hungry people aren't
riding and destroying everyone else to
steal their food
but man the pharmaceutical industry
pisses me off of course but but I do
want to say my favorite thing McDonald's
french fries so I do I'm thankful for
this technically modified uh yeah
McDonald's I don't understand how people
eat McDonald's
no no no I get Burger King Burger King
sausage McGriddle yes I just think it's
terrible there's not a single item at
McDonald's I think tastes good Tim they
perfect the pancake with syrup all right
which I love that method listen Burger
King Burger Burger King I find delicious
but disgusting Wendy's I find delicious
and not that bad pretty good Chick-fil-A
as lady pointed out the other day
actually probably the best Chick-fil-A
is good it's like premiums yeah but it's
not gay enough but you can't go there
yeah no well now it is now they've like
the chickens are good yeah they started
supporting all these organizations yeah
I'm pretty sure but you talk about
Postmates and I want to thank Postmates
gosh they have a bottom friendly menu
and that's so good yeah we love the
bottom friendly menu That's that well
you don't want that you don't want to
poop all over the place no no know about
uh McDonald's
to me it is it's all tastes like plastic
and chemicals I just I just I don't
exactly and you know it's created in a
lab to do that that's why I had a
mechanism in your taste buds you're like
oh this is addicting and the more you
eat McDonald's the more you crave
McDonald's so you know what the worst
thing is
the mayonnaise at McDonald's is like
flavorless slime
yeah flavorless Burger King it's good
you see those chicken nuggets that pink
slime oh it's delicious when it hits
your lips because the chemical reaction
in your brain it is like you know almost
like crack cocaine it causes you know
euphoric sensation to some people you
know what I had today I had tuna it's
funny so you're very the tram though Tim
I didn't realize you're in good shape
why I lost a lot of weight since since
uh November of last year I stopped
eating sugar grains cut out the wheat
the wheat apparently is like the worst
part it's inflammatory I guess I'm not a
nutritionist I don't know what oh you
look good all I know is I was like I
don't want to eat the bread or the rice
or the fried anymore so I started eating
a lot of chicken wings that's like 70 of
my diet right in an air fryer or what no
just regular chicken wings but do you
bake them because you said no fried I
should go to the restaurant and say give
me chicken wings I Love It I Like Old
Bay wings like so there's no extra sauce
or anything on them Old Bay rocks yeah
no no of course and then uh uh for
breakfast I've been doing like we have
our farm fresh eggs like the chickens
poop them out
I just eat that with like some uh some
like local cheese or something people
have been talking about how
in particular has a very
very deep like food quality problem
compared to the EU because we don't have
strict enough regulations from the FDA
and our Regulatory Agencies I think it's
all the way around yeah do you think the
EU is too strict no we are too strict
yeah we are yeah so uh so like our eggs
are like what are they like stripped
bleached and like are milk is so
processed as well yeah yeah raw milk is
illegal
come on raw milk is illegal you know
what else is illegal uh wine berries
that's right is that true so I took a
bunch of illegal berries no they're
illegal in New York and Connecticut what
if you ate one here and went back to New
York and they're like it's in your
system we're testing you for wineberry
get down so uh uh yeah wine raspberries
are everywhere they're invasive they're
thick brambles and they grow like crazy
and they're delicious by the way people
love it but in New York and Connecticut
they're illegal to possess
or sell or Trader but fentanyl's not
that's decriminalized so yeah well
that's the funny thing I'd be willing to
bet if you were in New York and you like
brutally beat someone they'd let you out
of jail but if you're caught with wine
barriers they'll be like serious
violation yeah I mean that just shows
you the hypocrisy of the rules in New
York and you know a big District like we
said AOC who's the queen of New York you
know people were literally defending
their bodegas and going to jail there's
a point that I made the other day uh so
we ordered this uh uh like you can order
these like food things
um one of the things that we promote on
the podcast version of the show is the
moink box and it's like farm fresh meats
delivered right to your door and so we
got one of those but with Seafoods like
scallops prawns fish and I'm eating this
wild white Alaskan salmon that is so
delicious and that's all it is you know
it's like lemon pepper on it with some
like avocado Tim do you use an air fryer
I hope you're using an air fryer do you
have an air fryer in this house yeah
it's the best kitchen actually they say
it's good in there I don't eat salmon no
I swear they say you can air fry it's
delicious what I said was this is an
expensive thing to order like to order
this wild caught salmon to like to your
door and then I'm like it's funny if
you're like well off in America you're
eating food quality up here if you're
middle to lower class you're eating food
quality way down here if you live in
South America and Africa you're eating
food quality way up here it's crazy that
the poorest people in the world not
everywhere not not some of them are
eating mud but there are areas where
people have like mud Huts but they walk
out catch a fish and are eating fresh
caught salmon and that is better quality
food than the mac and cheese McDonald's
stuff that people are eating in this
country and Americans get sick when they
go to countries like that because
they're not used to eating real food
yeah but the biggest point that you made
in that whole thing is that the middle
class is basically getting destabilized
there's you know the middle class is
disappearing here in America and that's
what built this country or I think
that's the most important class in this
country and now they're they're making
it worse just Elites and the super poor
and so if you don't realize you can see
the forecasting they're saying oh food
shortages you know energy shortages all
that does is destabilize the middle
class or this massive inflation where
people cannot take their kids on a
vacation they can't afford to feed them
in a public restaurant I think it's a
culling
um I'm not saying it's an intentional
culling but there is a culling that is
that is happening to a degree with food
shortages with the stress on the supply
chain what we're going to see is the
poorest people in the world are going to
be left destitute and desperate and the
elites the upper class the people they
don't care and you can see this in uh
the voting patterns the Democratic party
has become the party that has become
more white and more upper class the
Republican party has become more working
class more blue-collar and more diverse
Democrats don't care about talking about
inflation they don't care about pumping
money to the economy what they care
about is January 6 because they're all
you know they're they're in houses that
are on on the hills and the water is
rising and the people voting for Donald
Trump and the people on the ground are
watching the water rise around them
they're freaking out the Democrats don't
care those people don't vote for us I'm
in an affluent neighborhood in Dallas
and that's what they're called Limousine
liberals I mean they're not worried
about the massive inflation so if you
don't think that you know the social
justice lifestyle is basically people on
the left that aren't even affected by it
you're wrong so you're 100 right when
you talk about that that's what I that's
why I brought the war machine earlier
because I feel like I I'm I think that
we are and I'll speak for all of us here
from a severely affluent environment
where I've never suffered starvation
ever in my life never expected well I'm
not from that I've been hungry well at
this stage of your life you are maybe at
this stage I don't think I am not you
know were you ever technically starving
I mean you may have been hungry yes
starving starvation is when your body's
like wasting away kind of thing and I
was so that's it's pretty brutal and I
my my cheeks were sunken in I had black
rings under my eyes and I was eating
oatmeal cream pies once a day oh well
you're lucky access oatmeal cream pies
um some people eat mud like you said
earlier right and are willing to kill
for food but it'll literally kill and
steal I I was like emaciated and I was
uh uh you know I weighed like 139 pounds
or whatever and then I slowly you know
clawed my way out of that it's brutal I
lived in New York I was living in my car
I had food stamps thank God or I would I
was washing my hands with rain water
because I didn't have that but nothing
like nothing like the poverty of
desperation that will drive people to
kill for food and and access to water so
that's why there's a war machine I mean
I mean that's part of why there's a war
machine is to conquer
rivers and food crop land
you keep saying war machine
um and you said that it's something
that's existed throughout all of human
history
but it sounds like something unique to
the Modern Age and Modern Warfare no no
it's it's just it's it's crazy it gets
crazier and crazier so like in the early
days you'd have a tribe of 30 people and
they'd be like running out of food well
I don't want to die so they all get
their weapons and say then we gotta kill
them and take what they have and so
you'd have warring factions because they
were scarce resources Europe was crazy
with it more population than they needed
food and then people were like it ain't
gonna be me so they'd start fighting and
they try and take land and then take
resources that's not an apparatus that
controls the allocation of resources
throughout the entire globe that we have
now
is that what Ian was referring to um the
war machine is definitely globalized
relative to what it used to be Rome was
pretty powerful in its day I think
Atlantis before that had like global
domination status if if if Atlantis were
real which it very well might not have
been you can't say that on YouTube and
there's not a lot of documents
I love the Flat Earth videos on YouTube
what would happen pretty good I mean you
know it's funny that you know those Flat
Earth videos you know that gets uh
demonized so much but uh it's kind of a
company I know the Earth is kind of
shaped like a sausage McGraw okay I have
to say this
injected with syrup we can't get we
can't get enough Earth theory we can't
get we can't get on the Flat Earth sorry
but but I do think uh space is a little
uh elliptical well I'm a moon landing
expert because of Joe Rogan that's right
let me just tell you something the idea
that we could get through the Van Allen
radiation belts in 1969 through 1972 you
know we had uh we went through it twice
both ways is absolutely impossible yet
that same technology that was able to do
it then we accidentally destroyed it
it's a painful process
like just because they went through it
doesn't mean they went through it right
you know what I mean I don't know I mean
what they saw the Fantastic Dylan Buzz
lived for a long time I'm sure and and
maybe they got the best medical
treatment but I remember astronaut
saying it was crazy I was seeing Stars
it was like I was there and it's like we
we know that when you see the Sparkles
it's because you're being bombarded with
high levels of radiation so like yeah
but have you seen the press conference
Tim after they came back from the Moon
they look like they were dogs that died
I don't care what anybody says Joe Rogan
actually argued two different times on
pin teller's show that the moon landing
was totally fake made very compelling
arguments and then walked back and I
love you Joe I'm just saying you know uh
you know it is what it is and and you're
going to be like well Alex you know
you're just some conspiracy theorist
idiot I'm just telling you you look at
the point I think there's a compelling
argument as to why they would fake it I
just oh but I just also think like
strapping some dudes to a rocket isn't
as complicated as a lot of people think
it is well I don't know about that I
mean you know in Trump just even said
you know he was trolling Elon Musk and
said his Rockets go nowhere I don't know
I mean you know rocket technology you
know space travel I'll just be honest
with you you know what is it pushing off
of you know uh and sometimes you say oh
well blah blah blah blah I don't know I
think space is kind of fake but what am
I going to say yeah I mean you know what
do I know I'm an idiot uh but yeah what
they tell us you know I just I don't
think I get them I get the feeling all
Snopes you that you're partially true or
partially false whatever you want to
call it that that they did print fake
documentation of people on the moon
Stanley Kubrick for instance did video
in case they didn't have enough footage
from when they went that's a fact you
know that for sure that's oh yeah well I
think the theory is that it's all faked
because Kubrick's footage proves it but
I think that what they did both they
they went there just in case they didn't
have enough um propaganda to convince
people and make them excited that they
shot more in a studio they were going to
enter the lace and some of it may or may
not be interlaced I don't know but I
don't see evidence that we didn't I I uh
most of everything in society has told
me that we have and that we still do go
into space well just Google the fake
Michael Collins picture that they used a
picture with their training and they
admitted that it was false you know who
did I don't I don't think it's confirmed
in any way that Kubrick directed
anything about the moon no but he did a
movie exactly before she doesn't want A
Space Odyssey and you know they say in
The Shining that you know he left Clues
like you know the little kids wearing an
Apollo 11 shirt I know hey Tim I'm a
conspiracy theorist so I mean I'm just
I'm just saying I just what about
Atlantis oh I don't know but but Tim I
think you may I think you said that you
know the best point is like uh you know
the government did have an incentive to
you know lie and I'll be honest when it
comes to the government I don't trust
them at all I don't trust them on
anything so it's hard for me to be like
oh yeah I'll tell you I'll tell you take
a look at the uh space Feats
accomplishments of the Soviet Union in
the United States they were crushing us
the Soviet Union was crushing us on the
one thing we defeated them on was
getting to the Moon first which is a
reason why they would have lied about it
to be like hey we got there first so but
they say that Russia she would have
exposed us for but I don't know because
you know all these same people or at
least accused us of it yeah but you know
at the end of the day it's like if you
don't think that we're kind of In
Cahoots with everybody it's like you
know they want to let me tell you
something Vladimir Putin the ruble is
the strongest it's ever been so if you
don't think that this war is benefiting
Russia you know you know how I know
we've been to the Moon because we came
from the Moon because the Moon is the
ark and the reason the Russians didn't
expose us because it's because the US
and the Russians are actually both
working underneath the moon people who
control space force yeah yeah I know we
need it who is Dianne Feinstein I think
just said that space force is our most
important you need to pull that up she
just said it so these people that you
know are supposedly socialists they want
to spend all of our money in space I'm
just saying I think that you know it
spends a lot of money going and
exploring these planets that we could
spend here it's similar to the war in
Ukraine we need to help out our citizens
base exploration is more of a morbid
curiosity now compared to
an optimism in the past I I think it's
great the money spent on space travel is
spent here the people who get the money
for space travel get that money buy
things here and expand the economy and
the technology developed from space
travel has widely improved a lot velcro
what space technology is in Plastics
you don't think they would have invented
Plastics without space um either way
it's it's their programs but but also
we're looking at mining asteroids which
is oh sure we're gonna get diamonds from
asteroids come on you know did you see
that they just found enough diamonds or
gold I think in Africa uh you know
trillions of dollars worth of gold in
Africa so yeah you know these people
where was that Congo or something yeah
so you know they say these precious
materials oh there's old wrestlers we
don't have any yeah like I said earlier
we have enough oil and gas reserves in
Texas you know to uh support the whole
world if we can get to the Moon with a
mining operation we can access the Lost
ancient technology of the Ark wow it's a
movie that just came out of course of
course
I'm just saying you know the government
I trust them with every decision that
they make and you saw Bill Clinton was
recently on James Corden show and said
like Area 51 was not aliens or whatever
I I just it's kind of like this there's
a guy Warner Von Braun who was actually
brought over in a Thing Called Operation
Paperclip and Warner Von Braun did he
designed the rockets that actually you
know killed a lot of people in World War
II and we brought him over and we gave
him immunity and let him create the NASA
program and you know what he said well
his best friends about the the rockets
in World War II they performed
wonderfully they just landed on the
wrong planet uh well exactly but my
point being is he even said to get to
the moon we need Rockets about uh twice
the size of the Empire State Building
and Warner Von Braun uh said that and
there's multiple yeah but like that's a
really long time ago you know what I
mean so they tell me let me just compare
a 1969 Lincoln to a 2022 Lincoln which
is uh you know has more technology
the modern one what do you yeah so do
you think technology goes backwards how
did our space technology I'm saying our
technology in 1969 How does it go
backwards we cannot go to the Moon today
and NASA admits it we cannot travel 237
000 miles what do they say to the moon
what are you talking about we cannot
have manned space flight through the van
Google this uh Google uh cannot go
through Van Allen radiation belt right
now it'll come up and and if NASA will
say Google cannot go through a Van Allen
radiation belt it should come up um
right on YouTube and it's like a person
saying oh uh you know we do we're trying
to develop technology to go to the moon
but we can't do it now so we don't have
the technology now Tim to spin to send
human through the Van Allen radiation
bill yet we were able to do it in 1969
so it's the only technology where did
where did Nessa say that we'll go to
videos go to videos click videos
and you'll see and you'll see it's
probably you know obviously it gets all
uh it's like a woman uh talking about it
and she says we cannot go through the
Van Allen radiation belts now type in
NASA to put NASA in the search but my
point being is is this video exists
somebody will be able to find it yeah
but are you talking about like a single
individual or there's we cannot go to
the Moon Tim that's a fact that NASA
admits that and there's more you're
wrong there's multiple oh Tim I'm not
listen I'm telling you there's multiple
videos saying uh why aren't they we
cannot go to the Moon I'm telling you
that's official story from NASA is that
like you can't eat raw milk no what kind
of thing we're like if you decided it's
too dangerous for you so now you can't
do it here I'll find the video but I
can't and shouldn't are two different
things I'm telling you NASA today cannot
go to the Moon yet 1969 through 1972
with technology that we accidentally
destroyed pull up a picture of the lunar
lander right now if you if you want to
believe me just type in picture of the
lunar lander well let's start we'll
start here and then we'll keep moving
forward so I'm trying to find out where
NASA said we cannot get to the Van Allen
I found a Forbes article saying we
actually can oh yeah years ago yeah but
let me I gotta find it I should have had
five years ago uh uh it's just there's
so many videos I gotta now my service is
terrible but I'm telling you Tim we
gotta find the video where it says it's
very clear they say we cannot go through
the event Now go to YouTube right now go
to YouTube well let me read this real
quick
so this is this is them saying uh what
is it uh
they there were uh 0.38 rad
getting the irradiation does of getting
two CT blah blah blah the atmosphere can
be a danger but they made it through it
uh the power trips we wanted to send the
astronauts through a sparse region of
the belts and try to get through them
quickly
so yeah I don't I don't know Tim the
farthest we can go according to them is
the International Space Station which is
roughly about 200 of them who's them
NASA is it roughly about 200 miles from
uh the surface of Earth we cannot go
past low or oh type in type in cannot go
past low earth orbit uh Barack Obama
type that in right now low earth orbit
Morocco I'm not trying to beat boss you
just said you didn't believe the
government but this bill well of course
but but now to go to the video uh go now
click videos click videos it ought to be
the first one that Aggregates to the top
it says for the United States The
Landing the leading space-faring Nation
for nearly half a century to be without
Carriage to low earth orbit and with no
human exploration capability to go
beyond Earth no capability to go beyond
low earth orbit the Moon is 237 000
miles according to them that's past low
earth orbit you're reading it wrong no
type in Barack Obama I've got the quote
right here literally it's right here in
a quote he says there uh and with no
human exploration capability to go
beyond Earth orbit for an indeterminate
time into the future Destin's our nation
to become one of second or even Third
Rate stature he's not saying we've never
had the capabilities and we currently
don't please type in video just listen
to what Barack Obama has to say because
you're going to get all this stuff and
that's not the third one down the third
one third one down go down third one
this one yes
you got it you gotta this video right
here yes
so let me start by being extremely clear
Claire I am 100 committed to the mission
of NASA and its future
because
this is a minute long video but there's
a shorter one where he says it but we
can watch it
you might want to play it on 1.5 speed
because broadening our capabilities in
space will continue to serve our society
in ways that we can seriously measure
because exploration will once more
Inspire Wonder in a new generation
sparking passions and launching careers
and because ultimately if we fail to
press forward in the pursuit of
Discovery we are seating our future and
we are seeding that essential element of
the American character
I know there have been a number of
questions raised about my
administration's plan for space
exploration especially in this part of
Florida where so many rely on NASA as a
source of income as well as a source of
Pride and Community we start by
increasing NASA's budget by six billion
dollars over the next five years by
buying the services of space
Transportation rather than the vehicles
themselves we can continue to ensure
rigorous safety standards are met but we
will also accelerate the pace of
Innovations as companies from Young
startups to established leaders
compete to design and build and launch
new means of carrying people and
materials out of our atmosphere yes
pursuing this new strategy will require
that we revise the old strategy
in part this is because the old strategy
including the constellation program was
not fulfilling its promise in many ways
that's not just myself okay edit it out
you got to go to the you got to click
back go to YouTube and you're going to
see a short version type in Barack Obama
low earth orbit you got to go to YouTube
Obama low earth orbit and there'll be
like a 10 second clip of him saying it
that we cannot go through yeah that's
him speaking uh we got to go down
you gotta see it's it's that speech
there he says he cannot go through low
earth orbit I promise you dude I mean
it's just kind of annoying I mean I read
the quote where he said no but you have
to hear him say because he doesn't say
that quote he does not say that he says
it he says it much different he says we
do not have the ability to go but it
can't even reach low earth orbit I mean
with transcript right here right
I'm just saying I mean you know he
called me a conspiracy theorist but this
is Barack Obama saying few people you
know the same the same people that type
this transcript are the ones that said
bro that Joe Biden didn't say uh sure
but he says sure it's comfortable but it
can't even reach low earth orbit and
that obviously isn't striking contrast
to the Falcon 9 rocket we just saw on
the launch pad which will be tested for
the very first time uh I mean here's the
issue like anything they don't want
shared We're not gonna be able to just
Google search you know what I mean well
it's but on YouTube there's a lot of
control go to go to YouTube and then
type in upload date type in Barack Obama
low earth orbit then type in upload date
and then it'll it'll be one of the first
ones type in Barack Obama low earth
orbit there it is recent search
suggestion uh it'd be a really short one
and did you do it by upload date uh
search by upload date where is that
uploaded to the right to the right to
the right yeah okay and we want to go
from reverse uh yeah well you want to go
down where it's that short I think is
that maybe that nine second one up there
Obama says we can't go nine second one
this one does that say what does that
say next day this is it
early in the next decade a set of crude
flights will test and prove the systems
required for exploration Beyond low
earth orbit in the next decade but I
don't think you understand what that
means and second of all this is a nine
second out of context clip well you can
watch the whole context I'm just saying
he admits today with the technology
where you can fact checks he says today
that we cannot go through low earth
orbit we cannot take manned flight
Barack Obama said it right the idea but
if it doesn't exist it means we don't we
don't we don't have it we don't fund it
we don't have it yet we did have it 1969
through 1970 and then they stopped so
you're telling me technology goes
backwards Tim you actually believe that
like there there was a lot for a long
time for a long period they wondered how
the Romans did concrete underwater right
for for a long period we couldn't build
skyscraper you're comparing space flight
with concrete Tim okay how did they
build the Pyramid let me well I'm just
saying we can't we can't rebuild the
pyramids right we can and we know how
because I've read about the construction
of the pyramid oh you got to be kidding
these these uh Freemasons I'm just
saying some of the designs so now you're
saying it does go backwards well exactly
my point being though not spacious it's
really simple we had a reason to go to
the moon when we were in the Cold War
afterwards we abandoned the projects and
abandoned the rockets and they found the
disrepair and no one cares anymore now
now we have no real reason to build and
expand in that in that direction or we
don't have companies that want to do it
nor do we have the government want to do
it and in 2010 Barack Obama was saying
we need to start building the machines
to do this but we don't have the
machines today you admit that right I
don't know based on what he said 12
years ago we did not have machines
capable of doing that doesn't mean the
technology
did not build them and Barack Obama's
literally saying in these videos we're
going to put six billion dollars into
NASA to build these to do these things
and we can't go today they keep saying
we're going to go to the moon and let me
tell you something you know this as a
successful businessman it would be the
biggest marketing tool in the world if
they were able to go to the moon and yet
we can't so I mean but I don't
understand why you're saying we can't
like Elon Musk go to building Stars okay
Google if Elon Musk says we can go to
the Moon we can't Elon Musk is saying we
can go to Mars we can't go to the Moon
Elon Musk we cannot send manned
spacecraft they can say they can spend
it Cinder Rover Elon Musk said on
Twitter like a week ago we will be on
Mars and uh you will see men on Mars in
our lifetime he also wants to put a
computer chip in your brain to be able
to park your Tesla that's not a question
that that that's a morality question but
a question of the possibility of the
spaceships well you guys can believe the
moon landing all you want but it's so
fake and the government and it's so fake
for the record of Barack Obama said we
do not have a base on the moon I would
immediately think we probably have a
base yeah well there was a there was a
skit about that who did that as The
Whitest Kids you know have you seen that
one no he's like uh he's like uh there
are bears on the Bears on the moon he's
like and they're like did you just admit
there that was a great schedule and then
and then someone goes are we invading
Iran he goes you got me you got me and
then uh you know okay last thing because
then we'll get off the moon because
people are gonna get so mad at me just
type in a picture of the lunar lander
please lunar lander huh yeah just type
in a picture of it because I want you to
show you this great technology
now type in images
and now I want you to you know look at
that thing and you tell me that that so
you know you you know the idea of the
lunar lander is that they were able to
go what happened was is we were able to
send a craft to the Moon get in the
moon's orbit then Michael Collins stayed
in the craft and then that thing was
able to escape from this spacecraft and
it was able to land on the moon then
buzz and Neil were able to take a car
out of there and drive it around and
play golf on the moon Tim this is the
official story they actually snuck a
golf club Google snuck Golf Club yeah so
you're telling me NASA with technology
you're able to just oh bring your own
bag you know yet on an airplane if your
bag weighs over 40 pounds you can't even
take it on but these guys can take that
technology makes no sense well I'm
saying it's the joke is the fact that
they can just bring stuff on the on the
most intense Mission we've ever been on
but but look at this technology you see
that you see how that's held together
does that not look like that does that
not look like 2022 technology I don't
understand what you think is wrong with
it I'm saying that is the fakest looking
crap I've ever seen in my life that's
garbage well you got it you got to zoom
in on it look at that what is that tin
foil and what is that literally is foil
yes okay and that's paper and this is
according to them this you can Google
this that when in the and when they were
doing uh the uh you know practicing for
the mission that if they dropped a tool
that it was so thin the tool would fall
through
what through the through the uh whatever
you want to call it the walls of the
lunar lander you can Google this uh
tools would would break through the wall
of the lunar look at that that is tape
Tim that's space tape Bud that went
through that you know they put duct tape
on airplanes okay
when I worked two yes airplane when I
worked at O'Hare passengers would freak
out all the time watching mechanics put
mechanics put duct tape and they would
be like
okay so why can't we recreate that then
if it's just tape if it says we can't
recreate it because we can't go to the
Moon today why can't who says that
Barack Obama here's you're conflating
the lack of funding and motivation with
the lack of Technology Tim if with hers
you don't think there's motivated to go
to the Moon you're kidding me but what
for what what's what's on the moon
because it could be a marketing
technique you know the same reason oh
yeah let's spend 50 billion dollars to
Market when we were at War I get it now
they gave 80 billion dollars to the
Ukraine to fight a war we can't get
people to fund real journalism but we
can get all this money to go to Ukraine
come on right you can get money for a
war you can't get money for journalism
why would Tim get money for explaining
to me where did where did the car come
out of that machine I I'd have to
research I think you're wrong about
everything you've already presented no
I'm not so I'm right but you can't come
here and be like the car came out of it
and have me just assuming it did well
okay type in the moon landing Rover and
it's look at the car just look at that
Jeep frame yeah I've seen it yeah a Jeep
frame they were able to in a machine in
that thing they're able to pop out a
Jeep and drive you can't play a goal you
can make a lot of assumptions and I
would argue there is a good reason why
the US would fake such a thing but none
of what you've presented is actually
evidence that you're right it's
conjecture based on out of context
quotes and it does nothing for me to
believe you now you might be right you
don't have to believe me I'm just saying
you can you know you can just believe
the government I mean you know that's
what you know that's you don't have to
believe either though
I'm just saying the technology I'll tell
you one of the weakest points well this
is the thing but think about their
battery tell you one of the weakest
issues the foil on on the on the Lander
right here I actually know a little
about and I understand the concept of
using lightweight reflective foil mylar
for instance you seem to not understand
that so when you say that it's a red
flag for me being like well if you don't
understand that Tim I would assume the
like the outside of it your arguments
are incorrect well listen I'm not saying
that you know you can't say that you're
allowed to have an opinion but I'm just
saying if you actually do the research
you actually looked into it like your
buddy Joe Rogan did for a long time you
can pretty much find all the holes in
the story of the moon mission it's just
it's just laughable and I know we're you
know we're kind of going on a tangent
you're gonna know for sure like I tried
looking uh and granted there's there's
the issue of Google suppresses things
yeah it's like not not easy to be like
I'm gonna google it and we can prove
that it's a real thing but uh all I can
say is this
I don't know
about the things you're saying nothing
that I've pulled up has actually
confirmed what you've been saying okay
type in this importantly I want to make
the point when I understand the concept
of mylar or lightweight reflective foil
and you don't it's a red flag it's not
even about that because the foil I said
was so thin that a tool could fall
through that but they've actually gone
to labs for jet propulsion and like saw
them working on these things I actually
have a video of a rocket test at uh at
x-core in in the Mojave Desert and I
watched them fly a rocket plane so when
I actually sit down with rocket
Engineers and Machinists who are
building these parts to explain these
things to me and I know even the tiniest
bit as like a Layman who's like oh I
heard about that and then you say
something that's completely incorrect I
say okay well what did I say incorrectly
that's that that's foil that's space
foil you acted like the foil was somehow
proof that didn't make sense I'm just
saying that does not look like very
advanced technology to me that's what
I'm saying because you're basing your
mind your view on like Sci-Fi movies no
I'm looking and using common sense that
looks like it's held together by literal
tape you're and and the issue is I'm
right that it's tape you're wrong about
foil and you don't know anything okay
we'll type in this just type in
astronauts hands injured from the
spacesuit so multiple yes well I'm just
saying we're not going to get it done in
half an hour I know okay okay this is
the last thing but this is the last
thing I want to say and this is a fact
multiple astronauts when they came back
in the pictures they had scars on their
hands so this technology that was so
incredible and on the moon in the
sunlight it's 200 degrees in the shade
it goes to instantly negative 200
degrees now you can talk about the space
technology to get there all day long we
cannot even recreate the suits and on
top of that back then these suits the
most magical suits in the on Earth with
one battery that can go change 400
degrees in instant listen was not even
able to get the thumb mechanism right
for multiple glass because there's
astronauts that admitted that they had
thumb injuries when they came back the
problem with conspiracy theories is that
you choose to believe some narratives
but not others I believe all the
narratives it's fake that's all I'm
saying so so if they can't get the glove
right then they can't get a battery
technology that can make a suit change
instantly 400 Degrees the problem with
conspiracy theories is that you have
made a determination and now you agree
with the evidence that back to
determination well that's with
everything right I mean no no no I don't
have that position my position is I
don't know well I mean I well I do know
that we didn't I know that you're you're
like you you acted like the foil was an
incorrect thing and having actually I
didn't say it's incorrect I said it
looks like garbage it looks like a space
and you're shy wrong right so that that
to me wrong what do you mean I'm wrong
you don't think that you think that that
looks good to you the foil specifically
is a red flag in your argument because
you don't understand okay what other
than the foil what is that what is that
material I don't know what's the
material next to that blanket compromise
of 25 layers of capped on tape Gold Leaf
uh there's there's data about it we
could read into it right so so let me
stress this point because I don't think
you're getting it I don't know anything
about the Lander you don't either I know
a little bit you looked at it and said
that does not look right I said okay
actually I've been to a jet propulsion
laboratory in the Mojave where I watched
them do tests and they explain to me
heat resistance return all that stuff
and so you're comparing apples and
oranges but okay so so your
misunderstanding my point is when I've
actually gone to a Spaceport and look at
this stuff yeah and have witnessed the
test of it and actually flights of the
of the they didn't do the rocket test
when they went in the space in the in
the rocket plane they just flew it
around uh and then you come out and say
that looks wrong to me I'm like okay
well you're missing key context here no
so I'm not going to take your narrative
which is based on conjecture don't
believe me that's the first thing I want
to say is I'm not a role model I'm not
do not ever believe me I just think we
should question the reality in which we
live in and there's a lot of there's a
lot of unanswered questions with this
when you talk about the original footage
that they accidentally deleted you know
they recorded over all the television
someone said you're you're wrong the
Rover was not on the first mission it
was on 15 16 and 17 Apollo 15 16 and 17.
so this actually see we're wrong and
that's the problem I have yeah but I
said where's the Rover on that you were
wrong there wasn't a Rover yeah but look
over look at that look how fake that
looks I'm just saying it doesn't pass
the smell test and you don't want to
give it the smell test because you know
you're red white and blue I wouldn't be
surprised if NASA and the government
opted to throw false information out
there so that other people couldn't
recreate their process just like with
Area 51 they told people there were
little green men in the stuff to so if
someone went rogue and wanted to Spill
the Beans they're going to sound like a
crazy person well I'm just saying guys
you know you can believe the land I
don't think you're wrong to cast doubt
on it but you are saying with certainty
that we didn't do the moon landing well
I don't know a lot of stuff you know it
I in my heart I know and that's all that
matters because you know what we get to
choose how you believe in my heart I
believe and I believe that I'm a
thousand percent right but we can debate
the moon landing all day long I do
debate people on it but I'm not even
trying to debate you Tim because I like
you and I appreciate your opinion Oh I
thought it was fun I thought it was fun
and on a serious note though I'm just
saying you can watch a little
documentary by Bart sabriel if anything
happened on the way to the moon and when
he went and confronted the astronauts he
asked him to swear on the Bible whether
they went to the moon none of them did
and so regardless you don't you can
believe that we went to the moon and
that we lost that technology and it's a
painful process to build it back up
again Don Pettit on a NASA astronaut is
actually one that said it exact person
that said it and I believe less than 120
people have even been
two space so the idea that they could
fake it you know I think so here's a
poison Point um there was a period where
we only Built buildings up to eight
floors because the heat accumulation at
the highest floor was too intense and we
had limited technology preventing it we
invented window air conditioners and all
of a sudden we could now expand with
window air conditioning units as well as
centralized units now we could actually
sustain buildings all the way up because
we could funnel the heat out the sides
the funny thing is there are ancient
cultures that would build structures
that that would guide heat out of this
oh yeah yeah it was not necessarily a
lost technology but kind of was it was
it was amazing I was watching this
documentary we lost the technology in 50
years then this is in the thousands of
years like the pyramids is my point I
just don't see it as being impractical
that having no reason no commercial
purpose the government stops funding it
people stop funding it and then they're
like where's where's the old documents
in the construction for ah they did they
did lose all the old documents and they
lost the plans for building it it's just
so they just lose that to be like saying
oh we lost the Constitution you know
it's literally America's greatest
technological achievement and we just
accidentally control to delete it I
wouldn't say accidentally control
deleted it I just think there's a
possibility that without any support we
stopped doing it also like if I had a
brilliant cognitive dissonance but you
know we'll just agree to this I think
it's your cognitive dissonance you want
so hard to believe it's not real whereas
I'm asserting nothing no no that's not
necessarily true I wish you actually
went to the moon I just hate that we
didn't that's my point and see so my
position is
there is limited evidence that we did
and and conjecture uh uh you you have an
official narrative and you have a
counter narrative and I say I don't know
there's a motivation to fake it but
there's also rocketry has been around
for a while and we have icbms they're
very powerful and we have uh tons of
tons of explanations as to how we can
and have done it
you've not presented any hard evidence
I've prevented a lot of evidence but I
wonder if I haven't there's no literal
evidence you have conjecture okay
conjecture whatever presented a lot of
conjecture you've asserted a belief
based on what you've read which is
believing some narratives but not
believing others with no basis but
you're comparing like the technology of
some jet you know to what we're able to
do in 1960s didn't you just say you went
to jet propulsion lab or is that what
did you say you went these are rocket
engines excuse me rocket engines right
this is rocket propulsion yeah so uh jet
propulsion uh x-core Spaceport uh export
was the company I think they exist
anymore uh I watched them do a rocket
test I wonder why they went out of
business because rocket planes are
impractical
Los Angeles to London in two hours by
entering outer space and then dropping
down you go straight up then you go
through space where you can travel super
fast then you enter the Atmosphere by
spiraling down and it's just it's
prohibitively expensive so it was
invested in and they ultimately said no
one's really going to want to spend the
money to travel this way it's not that
hard to fly on a plane for 12 hours so
that's why that ended so when I go to a
lab and I see these things I say oh
that's interesting that lines up with
other things I've seen in the past still
I I'll entertain the possibility they
did fake it I just I think it's less
likely and I don't know well it's
possible they did it and then they were
like yeah by the way it's impossible to
do so no one tries to do it like they
don't want other people to try and do it
they want to disincentivize that they
want to be the leaders so they're going
to pretend like it's impossible well
listen we can uh you know it's funny I
get we'll read super chats otherwise
okay yeah no but yeah and I agree and
it's funny because I you know I finally
get on Tim cast and then we have to go
full tin foil hat but I am Prime Time 99
that host of The Conspiracy castle and
you're welcome to sub to that yeah
that's my it's called The Conspiracy
Castle
um but what I'm saying is and that was
actually before you called the cast
Castle but that's neither here nor there
what I'm saying is that's neither here
nor there my point being is do not
believe me do your own research it's out
there you can look into it and I don't
have my computer here if I had my
computer I could be you know blah blah
blah blah my internet service is not
that great because you know we are out
in the sticks but my point being is Tim
I respect your opinion and I think that
you're trying to hold my feet to the
fire and I appreciate that but at the
same time I only encourage people to do
excuse me I always encourage people to
do their own research including you
which you should listen to tonight Joe
Rogan on the pen teller show arguing
about the moon landing because he is
your bestie let's read some super chats
we got white owl says Tim why are you so
anti-big booty latina that's true dude
you got to be more Pro big booty latina
the bigger the booty
hey and you know on a serious note
though you know actually the Latin
Community does have a diabetes problem
so if you're out there and you do have a
big booty go walk around a little bit I
do not want you to get diabetes because
insulin here in America is extremely
expensive fasting also can be extremely
valuable if you look into that as well
and it is his spiritual value as well so
Kyle Schmidt says she only got mad
because he was Latina instead of latinx
yes that's fair latinx classic mistake
that is fair
all right let's grab some more Super
chats Andrew Starr says if you act
ridiculous it will show how ridiculous
the system is and will become in order
to push its boot on your neck
yes you're kind of like the Joker I am
from the move I am a little bit like the
Joker I do with a smile on my face well
you know um you know I feel like uh I
have nothing to lose you know I lost the
most important person in my life my
mother so what I'm saying is I kind of
do sometimes feel like the Joker like I
got nothing to lose I'm saying I'm
fearless because when I walked into a
room and watched my mom die it said it
kind of just showed me that I saw and
went through the toughest thing that
I'll ever go through so I can compare
any situation literally any situation I
can compare to that and think well this
is a piece of cake so confronting a
politician or going in sort of some
meeting and getting all the attention on
me is nothing as bad as holding my hands
holding my mom's hand while she died so
yeah I kind of am a little hardened by
that
well all right Raymond magaji says Tim
come on man let's be honest about the
facts every Vlog skit starring Ian AKA
Langston Stewart Jr III he steals the
show every time that might be a good
thing unless I'm a supporting character
all right let's see
Curtis Terry says Tim getting introduced
to you and Dan bongino around the same
time in 2016 literally saved my life so
thank you from the bottom of my heart
that being said I stood up for my
principles and against bullying and lost
my job
I got kids quit pushing fake news
receipts on Twitter
quit pushing fake news what is that a
reference to
who knows receipt's on Twitter sorry
sorry to hear it man but uh uh
tremendous respect for you standing up
for what you believe in
there are risks what was it we read this
I was reading this Plato quote it was we
talked about the one where it said the
penalty for uh being indifferent to
public affairs is to be ruled by evil
men but there was another one I read
where it said like
it's a maybe you guys know who this
quote's from it's like sooner or later
you'll have to fight for for what your
sooner or later there will be a fight
for your principles and values it can be
you it can be your children or it can be
your grandchildren better be you know
better for it to be you yeah yeah
somebody said that they said better that
it be me than my children that's a
Founding Father yeah something like that
yeah
rocket saw says this is for Langston
Stewart Jr III dope is for dopes keep it
up dope you guys gotta check out Cass
castle if you're if you're not in on the
joke you will be as a super chatter said
today Ian is our favorite Nixon
conservative
all right
what do we got here
do you read all of them does it matter
how much they pay for the ones that are
more expensive you tend to gravitate I
try not to not to just uh get the big
ones it's a mix right you don't you're a
socialist supercharger yes because some
people can't afford to give 100 bucks
but they make good points some people
will give a lot of money making really
bad points intentionally hoping that the
amount of money will make me read
something that is like not good some
people will try and promote stuff and
use it as an advertisement and within
reason we'll we'll read some of them you
know for the most I'm like going through
and I'm like reading the ones and I
really am I always try to find like the
good questions and the good points not
to like say that you know people
shouldn't you know like I won't read you
know but I read some that are inane and
just we'll grab what we can but I but I
usually I want like good questions right
of course yeah so before I move on I
just want to read this quote real quick
because it's really good and I'm glad
you brought it up this is from Thomas
Payne it said I prefer peace but if
trouble must come let it come in my time
so that my children can live in peace
the other the quote I mentioned was a
different quote from someone else that's
interesting yeah similar similar is that
there will be there will be a fight it
will be fought either by you your
children or their grandchildren
absolutely it's better that it's you or
something like that and we're in that
fight it's called the culture War yeah
100 percent
kefka says the taking down of the
American flag is the act of tearing down
the statue will of the people is for the
cycle to continue interesting and the
American flag is kind of considered a
hate symbol by the people on the left
remember when those shoes got canceled
that has had the the original flag on
them yeah the Betsy Ross flag yeah they
got what fresa hate speech it was like
offensive so they apologie apologized
and pulled the shoe or something my
favorite shoe was a little nazex shoe
that had blood in it oh yeah I tried to
wear them but you know I can't wear them
how did it have whose blood was it a
baby's blood no I don't know I'm just
kidding I don't know because like how
many did they make you know well it was
actually a third party thing they took
old back stock shoes and did it so it
ended up being kind of I thought it was
supposed to be his own blood something
like how much blood did he want it was
just it was supposed to be one drop of
blood into all of the paint yeah
something like that I mean who knows
come on fake news
all right Ken Ballard says how different
would our world be if Trump ran as a
democrat in 2016 and won PS Ian did
great in the recent cast castle video
yeah they're loving you Ian they're
loving you it was a big deal just join
us someday I'm down I know oh yeah we
should definitely where are you based
out of Dallas Dallas we gotta we gotta
get you on the Vlog let's go brother 99
I want to freaking I'm moving in I'm
sleeping up here tonight let's do it
Dylan Elliott says hey Tim what are your
thoughts on the fact that a second Civil
War will take place in an age of nuclear
weapons what do you think of the
possibility of a second Civil War ending
with portions of the U.S witnessing the
penultimate form of devastation
um it would be tactical it wouldn't it
wouldn't be
like icbms or anything like that
it's not just about nuclear weapons it's
about biological weapons too it's about
a whole lot of things about cyber
warfare and I know I hear you talk about
the Civil War a lot but you know I think
the only way that happens is if they do
repeal the Second Amendment take away
our guns what do you think would be the
interest in your opinion what would be
you can't take away guns I agree but I'm
saying what do you think would be the
straw that would break the camel's back
that would make people go on the street
and start shooting each other it's not
going to be like that it's going to be
um what I think is the highest
probability would be local militiamen
blocking Highway roads yeah and it could
start with like 10 people and it could
escalate into uh trucks with California
plates are barred from entering Texas
because let's say a woman in Texas gets
pregnant her husband says they're
married and the husband's like this is
great we're gonna have our third child
she says I don't want a third child and
he says well honey you're pregnant we
live in Texas and I want this child and
she says okay in the dead of night she
packs a bag she flies to Colorado and
she gets an abortion Texas says she
broke the law and she murdered the
church child of one of our residents she
kidnapped the child killed it in another
state where we recognize that as murder
the husband is freaked out and angry and
distraught and so you end up with a
conflict the feds refuse to get involved
then trucks from Colorado tried
delivering goods and local militia men
are like you are murderers who killed
one of our citizens turn your truck
around trade disruptions start then
that's the kind of thing that snowballs
and you'll end up then with like a truck
comes in and a couple and then the guy
in the truck gets out and says you're
not law enforcement get out of here
don't point that gun at me fighting
breaks out someone dies then state law
enforcement from Texas says to Colorado
now your guys are shooting at our guys
the feds refuse to get involved then
Texas says we're going to send people to
extradite that woman who murdered a
child we won't stand for this that's the
kind of ideological escalation that
results in Interstate conflict then the
feds finally say okay now local law
enforcement or National Guards are being
rallied up we got to get involved and
then you get a left versus right versus
Federal strange Civil War scenario
possibility not saying it will happen
but so you kind of break it down it'll
almost be like you know Texas in Florida
versus you know New York and California
sponsored by Pfizer so with the original
with the first Civil War
I think it was seven states I usually
get the number wrong seceded before
Abraham Lincoln was even president and
the other states joined after Abraham
Lincoln invaded and started fighting
against the southern Confederate against
the Confederacy to pull them back and to
force them into the union and so it's
possible that
what starts is
I'll put it this way
the reason Texas joined the Confederacy
was because they had no choice they by
geography that's what was stated you
know they were they were relatively new
to the union they were offered up to be
five states before they came it just had
to be one big state and then when when
the Civil War breaks out for trade
reasons and Association they were like
well we're here next to all of the
Confederacy we we have no connection to
the union at this point so we we just it
was it was it was practical they could
have gone either way some states could
have so the POS the probability is you
you might see with the abortion stuff
circumstances and I think you know what
could be a small catalyst is like a man
and a woman are together maybe they're
not married and the woman gets pregnant
and the guy says you have to keep it no
one says no and flees that's a crime in
Texas or maybe Oklahoma is a better
example facilitating or trafficking and
abortion or I think Missouri passed this
law in March and the guy who lives in
the state is victimized and his unborn
child was killed so he wants Justice the
state petitions the federal government
for intervention the federal government
refuses the state goes in uproar they
start borrowing access to citizen to
residents of other states saying no
because not until that person is
extradited and the FEDS won't intervene
and you know there's a potential there
you know and I'd actually like to get
your opinion on abortion because even
people that are pro-choice actually
agree that there should be some sort of
limit you know maybe not in the third
trimester so what do you think about the
politicians trying to do it up to birth
oh we talk about all the time they're
psychotic yeah I mean I mean that's just
that's just satanic or demonic and in
the conservative World they say
everything satanic and demonic for me
not even the people you know even the
people that are pro-choice believe there
should be a limit so it's just very
weird that our politicians want it up
into birth even after Democrats all
right let's read some more
Cali the French says crazy Kamala bailed
out people who committed actual severe
crimes but spent her entire career
putting away people who committed
misdemeanors if that
that's right yeah three strikes and
there's a guy you know that had two
felony convictions and then got a
misdemeanor and it was a third strike
and spent their life in prison wow
Raymond Laura says do you think AOC is a
decent person that's being influenced to
push specific policies and it has
created a character we've seen since
Alex confronted AOC with Latina and she
never corrected him with latinx she just
lashed out at her handlers
um I think AOC isn't like an NPC right I
think she's just blindly bouncing
between whatever you know what like
whatever gets her power that's it that's
why she gave you a peace sign so let's
do a selfie and peace sign and then
later came out saying I was gonna deck
him it's like why don't you give him a
peace sign and waved and then left well
you know the reason why is all these
politicians are so emboldened to their
funding and so like I said there have
people that make the decisions for them
basically and she knows you know whose
side she's on so she's bought and sold
like toilet paper at Walmart in my
opinion
all right
Abyss mom says Tim you have talked about
being as big as a daily wire one day and
I sincerely hope that happens any plans
for kid content I just want kid stuff my
kids asked questions spawned from ads
from June we actually do
um we started with chicken City and we
have those silly chicken City cartoons
and so we definitely want to make
content that is more kid-friendly and
educational we have a plan for local
community building and we actually are
working on a kids show right now it's
preliminary we have like merch planned
and I think it'll be a huge success and
a lot of fun and that'll be an age range
of like you know five to nine or
whatever just like
content we have we you know people work
for us our parents they've talked about
how they really just don't like the the
stuff that's being put out for kids
these days and we need to make stuff
that's why the daily wire is doing it
that's why we want to do it and it's
also a great Market opportunity uh a
wholesome family brand for kids is an
excellent opportunity to expand the
business we want to take it and we want
to make the world a better place I have
to talk about how inspiring kids is the
key to winning the future so that's
something we definitely have plans for I
can't say anything crazy like the daily
wire committing 100 million dollars to
it
but I can say we're gonna we got a show
in the works that we're really excited
for it's gonna be a whole lot of fun
yeah I'll be it'll be it'll be great
it'll be great
Krang says Alex Stein is a thick boy big
Politics on him I had him thick I'm
thick and thick Prime Time 99 is a
plant-based pimp so I may I basically
eat spaghetti and cheese pizza from my
meals vegetarian yeah vegetarian
plant-based about dog plant-based uh
grow your rice diet yeah but it's not
very healthy because I have a limited
option so like I said cheese pizza not
the you know same cheese pizza Jeffrey
Epstein ate uh but yes uh cheese pizza
is my main diet Sterling Wilson III says
please watch Sword Art Online the
metaverse scenario-ish y'all talking
about I've heard about it you talked
about it I've seen I've seen it it it's
uh it's actually very good and worth
watching at least the first couple
Seasons I feel like it started to get a
little repetitive personally after like
the sixth or seventh episode but in
incredible theme definitely worth
checking out if you haven't seen it yet
Sword Art Online
Sam says there's some data out of Sweden
and the U.S that suggests ssris may
cause homicidal ideation in young men
ages 14 to 24 between one and three
percent up to three months wow I I
remember I was going to say something
about that but I wasn't entirely sure
that it's not just about suicidal
ideation it's about homicidal like it
makes people like nuts and want to you
know a lot of these mass shootings I
think they call them public suicides
people refer to them as because a lot of
times the shooter loses their life and
they want to take people out with them
because they want to kill themselves I
wonder if these if these first person
shooter games you can't say that no no
I'm reading a Super Chat oh okay yeah I
don't know what did you say well I
didn't hear you I just said some people
want to kill themselves but I don't know
if that's illegal oh no no illegal well
we we don't want people to do anything
no no no obviously not now all right uh
Samuel this is why I said oh man Samuel
nitsky says first Super Chat ever Tim
has clearly never had a double fish
fillet with extra tartar I'll quadruple
the super chat if Tim tries one on the
next IRL best show it and a and during
Lent you know the the fish fillet is one
of the most popular sandwiches really in
America yeah because people don't eat
meat it's super and it's delicious I
don't eat it anymore but delicious the
fish fillet is the one thing I would say
okay that is good
see you found something that's true wow
we found something that's like fish
delete that and not a sausage McGriddle
ah no seriously the filet of fish is
delicious yeah and I think it's made of
something called like Hokey I think it
is I think that is hokey hokey yeah you
know Tim's a smart man and the fish kind
yeah it's a bony nasty fish a garbage
fish that nobody wants to eat did you
look it up is that what the Hokey
checking it out is it the Hokey fish
inside your official fillet boom how did
I know that weird memory yeah why do you
have those facts and you're right all
day every day non-stop for like a decade
it's insane the blue hake the blue
Grenadier the New Zealand whip tail or
whiptail Hawk it's like it's like a
hokie it's like it's like a it's like a
bony fish that like if you were to catch
on its own it's not really enough but
when you catch a huge amount of them and
you grind them up into a paste with the
bones
I think yeah healthy but but it's a
paste you know sorry digestion it really
is I mean a lot of collagen in in the
fish bones so it's good for you okay uh
the filet of fish is good I gotta hand
it too we found something we found
something there's our Common Ground our
treaty as it were we can go to
McDonald's and I'll get the filet of
fish yeah yeah a double filet fish got
cheese on it and the tartar sauce is
good well Tim and I hope you don't get
mad at me for saying this and you know
obviously Tim is incredibly well known
and he is a celebrity obviously and Tim
said one of the most
terrible things I've ever heard is that
Tim can not really go to a restaurant
anymore that makes me oh yeah yeah I
just hate that I mean I'm just saying
that is like honest to God that is just
really sad because you know I think
there's nothing bigger than Fat American
cultures eating at a restaurant you know
I mean that's like literally part of our
culture and you're missing out it makes
me sad people people I mean I got to eat
yeah you gotta be careful
um people don't understand like
there's no cameras back there and
there's no way to prove if someone puts
like bleach in your food yeah they could
you could get really really sick you
wouldn't know why and they're not going
to run a test on it people don't
understand this you go to the hospital
for stuff and they often they're not
going to be like is there bleach in the
system there's no reason if there's no
reason to suspect that they won't
actually test for it and then they won't
know and then they'll be like we'll give
you fluids and try and get you better
and then even if the only place you ate
was at One Restaurant you got sick how
do you even prove the person there with
some lunatic who is actually trying to
ruin your food or get you sick Donald
Trump when he goes out this is why he
does fast food so often because it's
pre-made so no one tampers with it and
he can he knows that and so I was when I
was reading about Kavanaugh eating at
the Mortons I was like did his that did
security go into the kitchen and watch
the food get made
well Morton's is a pretty classy
restaurant doesn't matter I know I know
I'm not arguing on that like you think
the person in the kitchen isn't going to
be sympathetic to the left or hate well
it doesn't matter Ian might like this
one but this is a little secret for the
kids out there and obviously drugs are
the worst thing ever but you know the
kitchen culture is the biggest druggiest
you know World there is I'm just saying
like Stoney Stoney exactly I'm just
saying the kitchen culture and I think
Anthony Bourdain you know kind of
exposed that diners are fun you ever go
to the diner where you watch them on the
grill right there on the spot yeah I can
go there and Waffle House yeah but the
problem is if I go to an area That's
Heavy blue and people recognize me and
then I just say I trust you with what
I'm gonna put my body right now they
could at the worst spitting it or I
should say at the least you know if
they're angry with me they don't like me
spit in it and there's no way I'll know
and I'll eat it or they can do something
seriously bad like biologically tamper
with it and there's no way to prove it
and uh I've gotten sick eating out
before and it's like I've had people
recognize me we I've had issues at
restaurants with like okay I probably
shouldn't eat here there's there's
places where you can see the ideological
stuff on their walls I've gotten emails
from people being like hey watch out the
people at this restaurant know who you
are and it's like okay we gotta take
that seriously now it's like people
people we've gotten swatted so many
times I've gotten death threats enough
where you get to a point where you
literally can't just go to a restaurant
sit down and be like I'd like the wings
please
that's a harsh reality you gotta do
weird things like have someone order the
wings for you sit down and then I can
walk in and sit down and eat it
the price of Fame folks it's not just
it's not just about Fame it's about Joel
the the level of violence in this
country right now and the fact that
there are people who like a guy punched
Jack besobic in front of police and then
they all lied about it so you know these
are things people have to consider well
let's consider this did Amber Heard poop
in Johnny Depp's bed oh I guess you did
it was the dog
that was the dog we're gonna read a bit
more because we we argued too much about
the moon so I know I got I feel like I
got we got
to see vibrational energy and I kind of
Alexander Nelson says my in-laws are
ranchers in North Dakota and the beef we
bought from them recently is like
nothing we've experienced from any
grocery store I'm the uh in the end it's
cheaper to buy in bulk as well check
them out at Dakota Angus LLC not sure if
they deliver but it's worth a trip we
get a lot of farm fresh meat drive up to
a local Farm you walk right up pop open
the freezer grab out a big chunk of
fresh farm beef pay for it bring it back
and eat it well yeah you can buy like
half the cow that's a big deal in Texas
where you just buy the cow and so we
have we have so many chickens right now
what do we have like 30 something
chickens I love it yeah and they all
they're all screaming tons of eggs big
eggs too yep we get a crazy amount of
eggs it's so awesome I'm gonna eat some
of those tomorrow the good news is for
those that follow chicken City Sarah is
nearly all recovered excellent she got
really sick we had she went to the vet
they gave her fluids and antibiotics and
she made it yeah she had some kind of uh
chicken infection oh I think I had the
same thing but it was just monkey pox
yeah I was just hanging out at Pride
it's not a big deal I saw an article
that was like San Francisco at risk of
monkey pox I'm like is it because of the
poop in the streets no that's Pelosi
because uh it is it's already been
officially reported it's being
transmitted mostly among gay men
different Vector yeah oh and guys I want
to say this I just want to thank you uh
you know Nancy Pelosi because did you
see you know her jugs that she's
actually gonna in the baby formula
crisis with her own breasts selfless
they're so big a lot of milk we have two
super chats I want to read back to back
OMG puppies says is this guy trolling
Tim or does he really believe this and
then armchair quarterback says Alex's
right space is a hoax pick your poison
pick your poison guys either or like I
said I'm not a role model do not believe
me do your own independent research so
you know I'm like Charles Barkley in the
80s you know I ain't no role model dog
just asking atherin zala says the
greatest evidence that the moon landing
was not faked is Russia it was the Cold
War and Space Race if Russia thought for
one instant that America had faked it
they would have let the world know or
they would have I mean I'm surprised I
didn't even fault they didn't accuse it
anyway they should have just tried to
say it well it might it might have
started a war I mean there's a reason
why it was a cold war that you know we
never had
all right all right all right we'll uh
grab some more stuff see Ian's face
because it's it's a touchy subject guys
because you're talking about
geopolitical conflict and we live in a
world where we don't know we don't
necessarily know the truth there is
Declassified levels of information Neil
strong says I'm really trying to get
others to join us and listen to you but
man is uh it's a breath of fresh air
when I listen to a podcast like tonight
JRE compromised it seems I don't think
Joe Rogan's compromise I think Joe Rogan
is what Joe Rogan's always been he's a
Discerning regular guy who isn't a
culture Warrior I think people need to
understand like we are culture Warriors
here we are very concerned about culture
we want to influence it we directly say
that we challenge it we pay to expand
upon it and Joe Rogan's a comedian who
wants to hang out with his friends and
have interesting conversations who gets
pulled into these things because he just
will tell the truth when it comes to
certain news stories but you can't
expect him to be a journalist and like
dig up all of the facts and then
challenge them you know the way we do
well he used to be a little he used to
be a little more competitive but what do
you think about him saying he didn't
want to have Trump on I mean I agree I
don't believe you won't have Trump on
but do you think Trump wanted to come on
yes okay absolutely yeah and I think Joe
uh basically admitted that uh
Joe admitted that Trump would would do
really really well on his show and it
would it would help him yeah like Joe
Biden on Rogan would hurt Biden
tremendously Donald Trump on Rogan would
help him tremendously Joe said that so
for whatever reason Joe thinks would
help him you know
yep
all right
let's see Brandon Hill says Alex you are
misreading the context in Obama's speech
it was post space shuttle era meaning
not currently able not that we never did
yeah not currently able so I'm saying
the technology went backwards we were
able to go in 1969 through 1972 And I
just compare a simple you know
comparison examples and oranges you look
at a 1969 Lincoln you compare it to a
2022 Lincoln Navigator the technology
did not go backwards in that sense what
if we needed to
um store data on a magnetic strip in a
computer
well we actually deleted all the
Telemetry data and they said that we
needed it for you know further missions
but no what I mean is like let's say
right now there's a circumstance in
which we're like you know we want to use
tape drives yeah it's more reliable on
an EMP blast we don't have factories
that can make them right now do we
they've all shut down the production on
tape decks for for computers because it
was considered inferior or we didn't
have a reason to use it or we found
other means or like beta and VHS the
point is there's probably factors out
there that could quickly start producing
tape decks tape drives for computers
because it's not relatively difficult
but it would be really expensive you'd
have to fund it Finance it and create
the factor to do it and that's old
technology so there's older stuff that
we just stopped doing and now we're like
maybe we should rebuild that well they
admit that we went to the Moon with
technology less than a TI-83 calculator
you you agree with that right yeah of
course so we didn't have computers but
now through Zoom you can literally talk
to people across the world
I know well I'm just saying you know the
technology that they had able to call
Richard Nixon from the surface of the
Moon uh with like a three second delay
to me I I just think that and then it
took you know how many years 60 years
for us to get Zoom it's just the
timeline for me I don't agree with that
well but like Zoom is very different
from Radio you know radio it was very
simple in fact um hacker Buddies
237 000 miles away on the moon it's like
using radio yeah like yeah there are
there's there are people who bounce
bounce but you saw Nixon on a landline
talking to the astronauts you've seen
that right look man I know I don't want
to keep talking about it I don't I know
it's just I love Nixon like I think but
Nixon is the most honest president ever
so there are hackers who are trying to
take over satellites that want to bounce
bounce signals off the moon there was a
project that um I was in we were doing a
brainstorming session where we wanted to
use infrared laser pulsed into clouds
that could only be detectable by an
optical device so that you could
translate the flicker of it into
low-grade data signals or audio like
yeah there's really easy rudimentary
light and radio wave-based technology
diff that is very different from
encoding and decoding bits and streaming
it over you know hard lines and things
like that but I digress let's read we'll
just read a couple more here
and uh what's what we got reggae Vibe
says I think a civil war would look like
War Inc with John Cusack where
corporations are literally fighting and
funding the war along ideological lines
uh that's basically been the case
forever
like the Civil War in the United States
there were people funding you know
either side hoping for a victory on you
know for whatever
all right all right we'll grab we'll
grab one more what do we got
someone mentioning hollow points let's
see
oh and did you know you can make a gun
Vlog on YouTube but if you have a live
stream with a gun in it it immediately
gets canceled yeah yeah you can't you
can't handle guns on a live stream and
you can only handle guns in approved
environment so if you have a gun Channel
and you're on a range you're fine if you
have a gun Channel and you're in a
bedroom you're banned oh wow I didn't
know that I knew it had to be approved I
didn't know I figured maybe a bedroom
you could display the gun but you're
talking about you can't even like really
display it in a private room basically
all right is that is that what you were
saying Tim you can't can you display a
gun in a private room yes okay because
you can't handle it can't handle it yeah
because like Crowder had you can't
handle it oh yeah and there's like
decorative stuff and you know things
like that guys Crowder really pushes the
limit right I mean it was a holster I
know I mean he's wild all right let's
see
the science change says there were six
crude uh crude as in mend U.S Landings
between 1969 and 1972 and numerous
uncrewed Landings
uh China also landed something on the
moon recently I mean the question is
like did we land the Rover on Mars did
we land uh what was the big thing the
Volkswagen size things we landed on Mars
was a huge deal and it was like really
scary because like the huge delay
between Earth and Mars for a radio
signal Rover yeah it was the the you
know curiosity maybe oh yeah maybe yeah
yeah so there's like a whole bunch of
stuff but uh you know or whatever hey
you know what uh we're gonna wrap it up
it's Friday night my friends if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
if you really like it and become a
member at timcast.com to watch all of
the awesome shows we had this week the
Dave land I wanted we're really hyping
up because he's such a funny guy and it
was so good so become a member check
that out we could really use your
support we want to expand and make new
shows we're setting up venues we're
doing public events we're gonna do skate
contests all this culture and Community
Building we're really excited about it's
all thanks to you so you can follow the
show at simcast IRL you can follow me at
timcast Alex you want to shout anything
out it's Prime Time guys please follow
my Alex Stein Channel I'm almost to 200k
sub so if you guys could push me over
the top I would be honored and delighted
and I want to say Tim thank you so much
for having me on I really appreciate you
know we did a little debate but you're a
little mad about the way I treated AOC
but at the end of the day it opened the
door just like the Capitol Police so you
never know in the culture War what is it
going to take to be the Domino that
knocks down the bigger dominoes so we
got to keep fighting I appreciate you
fighting on the front lines right on if
you want to see me more often you should
go find me on Instagram or WeChat at
closer Kitty or you can go subscribe to
pop culture crisis on YouTube we go live
at 3 P.M Eastern Time noon Pacific time
every weekday and we talk about
entertainment news and movies and
celebrity gossip so come join us you're
going to want to watch pop culture
crisis from today if you haven't seen it
yet I was on the episode was fantastic
it went two hours largest Super Chat day
I think three crisis
obliteratingly awesome first time check
out cast Castle cause the action is hot
you're going to want to see that video
and see who I really am yeah it was
funny because the comments were like
this video video made me actually like
Ian yeah well
if you're in the way you're going to
capitulate like me man I love you and it
was a pleasure great to see you and
Lydia come on guys this is a good fun
show a little hopelessly a little
controversial you know the people at
home you know it's a little divisive but
sometimes in this you know we got to
kind of you know the people clapping it
doesn't always feel good you know it
kind of stings a little bit Yeah but
that makes it entertaining so correct my
personal theory is that Canada is not
real but that is an argument for a
difference I agree I know we'll get into
that later no I'm just kidding that's
not a big deal uh you guys we are huge
stands of Pop Culture crisis over here
you guys should follow them Brett works
his butt off to get that show lined up
and Mary it's great over there as well
uh as you know politics is Downstream of
culture so pop culture crisis first then
Tim Castile in the evening you guys can
follow me on Twitter and minds.com at
sour patchlitz as well as sour
patchlitz.me we will see you all over at
timcast.com well actually you will see
us there because we're not doing the
show tonight but also check out cast
castle and we'll see you all on Monday
thanks for hanging out bye guys